[inaudible] two one, boom. Hotep Jesus, how are you sir?
I was wanting to say that you want to call somebody that I need that drunk.
How the fuck do you get a name like hotep Jesus. How'd that come about?
It wasn't my idea. You know, I was a, I had just went through my,
a spiritual awakening.
I just thought the hip hop industry and I went through like that mace thing,
you know, you go to church, you doing with the headgear. What? We got you a lot.
A lot going on up there. I had to top my head down. It's a black thing.
So you had a spiritual awakening. I had this spiritual awakening and um,
you know, tweeting on Twitter like I do, right? And uh, somebody said,
what do you think you are some kind of hotep Jesus. Ooh, Ooh,
yes, I do think I'm hotep Jesus. That's perfect. And now you own it.
That person is probably like, Fuck God. Damn, that was a great name.
I gave that dude. Yeah.
I don't know who that person is or was or where they are now.
Shout out to whoever you are and vibe. Hi, you're Twitter.
Why didn't you switch it to hotep? Jesus, can you switch it? Ah.
Does anybody own a hotep? Jesus, I do.
You so you have hotep Jesus on Twitter too. Yeah, I reserved it. Oh Dude.
I think they could probably swap.
Do you have a little cute little blue check marks yet? No.
To put the fuck is that? How do you get one of those?
I don't know this and people,
there's some people that have those that have like a thousand followers.
How are you getting it?
Like if you worked for the New York Times or some shit go,
I'll do Joe and then I get verified. Right?
They know how Twitter feels about me. I mean, I think Jack likes me.
He's been in a couple of times, but I think the whole, they're,
they're weird man. They weren't, I mean I think all social media,
all tech companies want you to toe a line right now.
And if you're not towing that line and you're bringing on forbidden guests and
you have people that have controversial ideas, you know,
they'll have that finger on the button of getting rid of you.
They don't know what to do. It's just like radio, you know, like radio.
A lot of people don't know.
But radio has to play happy songs because happy people buy things. Yeah,
that's what, that's what the study say. Allegedly.
The Marketing Studies and advertising studies say people who are in a good mood
tend to buy things, right.
So the radio is supposed to play happy songs all day long and the radio works
for the advertisers, kind of like media and so on, so forth.
So social media is no different. You have advertisers.
So if there's people on the platform who are creating disgruntled crowds,
it could be hurting the bottom line. Yeah.
But Facebook's algorithm actually favors that. The way Facebook has it set up.
Like say if, if you, uh,
if you get into debates with people on abortion or something like very
controversial, they will start sending that shit to your feet. They will,
they will prop it, will,
they'll sort of steer it in your direction because the more you engage,
the more clicks they get, the more money they get,
the more advertising dollars again. Absolutely. Absolutely. Uh,
the Facebook algorithm is quite unique and, uh,
the way that things can go viral there. Um, Twitter, I feel like,
did the Twitter safety and counsel board, what do they call it?
Trust and safety. Is that what it's called? Something like that? Yeah.
So when I go and look at the entities that contribute to that board,
I kind of start saying, oh, okay, I see why certain topics are taboo. You know?
Um, there's, and when you, when there's a board,
those people on the board are the voice. They're the ones that have the opinion,
you know? So if your group isn't represented,
maybe you need to figure out how to get on that board. You know what I mean?
Right. I don't know.
Anybody's getting on that board is not going to happen and you'd better be left
wing if you're going to get on that board. I don't think there's any. Right.
What do you think like is I think Jack's more like in the middle.
Yes. I think he's closer to the middle. I don't think it's Jack. I think it's,
you know, Jack's working on a bunch of different projects. Um,
but I think it's probably, you know,
whoever else is in the office making the day to day decisions. Yeah,
I liked it a lot,
but I think jack is in the middle of a gigantic corporation and there's so many
people with so many ideas. Essentially
the founding fathers of our country had a great idea when it comes to freedom of
expression.
They felt like it was very important that you have free speech and they don't,
you can't be silenced. You can't be,
you can't be undermined by people who disagree with you because it's dangerous.
It's dangerous when someone can just decide that you can't have a voice anymore
and only their voice can be heard.
And we're kind of seeing that with Twitter and we're kind of seeing that with
Facebook and with Google and their,
they're deciding what could be heard and what not can be heard.
They think they're doing it for good reasons.
They think they're doing it to preserve our culture and our civilization and
they want to protect people from the election. Read it. Shut down the Donald,
the uh, the, the Donald Trump support a reddit page. Yeah.
That's not a good idea.
That right and right before the dem dem to be right before the democratic debate
and you know, that was like where all the funny memes come from and look man,
this, you can't do that. I mean,
just because if you have some people that are saying some shit that's bad on
there, get rid of those people. Get rid of that.
But you can't just shut down a whole forum. Like it seems, that seems insane.
Is there a reason for it and you kind of shut down and says it's quarantine.
Where fuck does that mean, does it have a disease for like temporary,
it's got Ebola, it's happens to people.
They got to do something that says there's violent threats.
I'm looking to see what repeated misbehavior. Violent threats.
Let's see. Skeptical. Very. It seems weird, right?
I feel like all of this stuff isn't it?
Like we're seeing what the first amendment is really all about,
why it exists. We're seeing it play out with all these social media sites.
I really think that, you know, my thing is with like the right thing, right?
It's very easy to create an actor, right?
The left can create a right wing actor online to pretend like it's
something out. Sure. It's something else. They can go in and read it,
do something malicious to get the whole reddit band right or an agent
provocateur. Yeah, exactly. And uh,
I never leave that off the table. When I look at instances like this,
when you say, oh, somebody was, it's the internet, everybody is anonymous,
you know, tracking this back to who it is, you know what I mean?
Or do you know what's conservative? Do you know as a Republican? Are you sure?
So, you know, I take these things,
these pieces of information with a grain of salt. Yeah, you should.
But is this election meddling? It kind of is, right?
Is what it feels like. If you're killing a whole sub, what it does, it depends.
I mean, so if they're really,
that would be really interesting if it turns out that it was someone from the
left that was posing as someone from the right in order to shut down a forum and
pretend there's death threats or, I mean, you look at Youtube, right?
And what's been happening with youtube? Even just the algorithm, you know, uh,
I'm pretty good with keywords. I do SEO Marketing,
so when I type in certain keywords or find certain things,
I know what's gonna come up or what type of content comes up.
Now when I type in those keywords, it's like ABC, NBC, ABC, see a dad.
And I'm like, that's not what I wanted.
They don't even talk about these keywords. What are you talking about? You know?
So when you start seeing that,
you start thinking about ink soc in Orwell in 1984,
socialism and communism and fascism and the degradation of society and,
um, a lot of control coming down. Um, you know,
people, you know, in some ways it's like,
was the internet created for freedom or was it country created for control?
Right? So it's two different pathways. We could probably look at that,
but it seems like in many ways they set us up to be controlled and they're doing
it through monopolies.
Google controls search through youtube and Google.
And by what you search, you can think it's a truth. But what did Kanye say?
Kanye say Google lied to you. You know, so I'm trying.
He says a lot of crazy shit though. You got to really think about that. He does.
And I like crazy. I do too. I'm a big fan of crazy. I'm a little crazy.
A lot of crazy sometimes,
so I appreciate his crazy side more than his calm side. Well,
great things come from wild thoughts. Right? Exactly.
I think the Internet was initially created to exchange information and then one,
it got loose to the general public. They realized what a crazy idea that was.
What I think we're seeing right now with the algorithms is that these
corporations are influencing these companies to say, hey,
when someone's looking for these things, how about you send them over to ABC?
How about you send them over to NBC? How about you? You know,
like we want to be able to get the first views on these things.
So if someone's searching for that, I don't know how they do it.
I don't know what they are, whether they have agreements with them, maybe.
I mean there's also a lot of copywritten shit that's on there that could get
youtube in some significant trouble if they have a really decided to pursue it.
Right.
And how many videos are on youtube that people have on their channel that are
just straight off of Fox News or NBC News or there's a lot of like copyright
protected content that Youtube is essentially profiting off of. Oh yeah,
yeah. They make a ton of money off that stuff. Yeah.
So they might have deals where they say, look, we'll send these people to,
you know, this first. Yeah. And that's why I say, you know,
and that's where the control comes in. You know, the advertisers,
advertisers are the ones paying, you know, for the platform to a thing.
It's not us to users that are paying for youtube spree. So who's paying, right?
Yeah. They're there. They're monetizing us.
They're monetizing us to users and the viewers. Yeah.
That's where it gets tricky, right?
Because as soon as the advertisers get on board, they said, look, we uh,
you know, we want to give you money but this content is not advertiser friendly.
Right. And then they start moving stuff around and demonetizing things and,
and with demonetization, the real thing that they're doing in a lot of ways,
whether it's intentional or not, is you're influencing what people post.
You're kind of, you're asking them to self censor. Cause if you say, hey,
you guys want to discuss abortion rights or you know, like there's,
there's some things that you start discussing them and they will automatically
dump demonetize you. Yeah.
Well who is the girl that put out the a abortion documentary. Right. And they,
each girl snatched that down. I forget what it's called. Um,
I'm bad at memorizing these things,
but there was an a basically an anti abortion thing that exposed some things
about abortion as a documentary and I believe that day it went up,
it got shut down. She had a re uploaded. Um, what's that?
Lauren southern might've been, yeah,
there's those two cute white chicks that everybody thinks are super racist.
Lauren southern and Tammy, Tammy, Lauren, Tomi Lahren, Tommy Lauren.
So she did a documentary, but then you have like a,
the James O'Keefe thing where you know,
he put up the exposing youtube and then that got, you know,
obviously they're going to take it down for the most recent one to expose
Google. Right, right. Yeah, I've been asking people about that. I'm like, okay,
break this down for me.
Is there any way that this could have been deceptively advertised or deceptively
edited? Like it's,
it seems to me like they're saying that they're going to manipulate search
results and they're gonna manipulate the way people see things because of the
2016 election. They don't want that happening again in 2020.
That's what it seems. What I'm looking at it absolutely.
That's exactly it looks like could it be doctorate? Of course. Good. You know,
that's, that's, that's always possible. But um,
when you go and experience it for yourself, like what I was talking about with,
you know, doing a keyword search, you start seeing the parallels.
Um, and then, you know, uncle Hotep, you know, he is, his channel was, you know,
doing great and then the algorithm flipped and they see no,
like he wasn't making the same money anymore.
So it's like I don't have to go to some doctor video or whatever video to
understand his problem.
The people around me are being affected by it. You know,
is this as a primary source? I don't have to look at some money internet. Um,
but I don't know. It's, it's
in a way I don't like playing victim with the topic. Right.
Steer Platform. Do what you want with it. We choose to be there.
We don't have to be, there does not another game in town though. It's not,
it's weird, right? When you think about how big the Internet is,
and there's only one youtube, right? And Vimeo and all those other ones,
they're great. But well, you know, I always related to the black community,
you know, the black community always say, oh, you know, white people,
this white people that white people, this white people would ask,
they're not giving us opportunity. And it's always like, well,
is that the only opportunity? Can you not create your own opportunity?
You know what I mean? So I never want to take a victim mentality and say, Oh,
you know, let's take Google with a court, you know, all this stuff. It's like,
if you want to do that, that's fine. That's not how I'm looking at this.
I'm looking at it longterm, like hooking up with Andrew Torb over at gap,
you know what I mean? And building tools. So, you know, we do a,
the coin bid app.com and uh, creators can actually, um, it's,
it's based upon approval right now,
but creators can go on there and receive bitcoin as a donation, you know,
so we're circumventing the things that happen like with the d platforming at
Patriot, right? And the other payment platforms for creators.
So we're creating tools to circumvent these things. So that's how I look at it.
I'm like, oh, Google's doing this great. This is a great opportunity here.
Let me seize it and let me build it. And B, you know, the alternative, you know,
I love to see that. Um,
is the alternative going to be Youtube and as popular? Of course not,
it's just not, but it's still a viable option.
You can still communicate with your people.
The number one communication tool for an influencer, what their,
what their a community is. Email, build your email list, right?
People still subscribe to your email list, right? That's not youtube,
that's not Google. That's your email list. That's your contact list.
So it's like you can complain about youtube or Google,
but you can build your audience almost anywhere.
It depends on how powerful you are.
Are you powerful enough to convince people to come to this other platform or to
wherever you are?
A lot of people are powerful enough to pack a room at $2,000 a ticket.
You tell me you can't get somebody to go to another platform for free.
Who charges $2,000 a ticket. Uh, I mean a lot of these speakers, you know,
like the Tony robins type cats, he charges 2000 bucks.
I think Charles like 10 yeah, I think,
I think some of his stuff is like 10 yeah.
But he's doing like these week long events where everybody gets together.
I'm going to turn to your Lord doing karate kicks session
when you, well, that's how you get the biggest check.
You got to create a bigger experience. So it's like, all right,
so we'll do it one day at two k right? It's like, well, how do I get 10 k?
It's like, well, let's just extend it for the week and you know, add like,
you know, the kickboxing class, you know, we'll
chat in a sauna. You just, you know, create that part of marketing, you know.
Um, but yeah, I'm not complaining about these tech companies,
these tech companies. Man, I'm not scared of these dudes, man. He did.
The content is us. The content is certainly us. And like I get,
what I got from talking to Jack and vigil was it's almost impossible to manage a
site like that. The just the influx of not like I used to have a,
a message board on my website.
One of the things that I noticed before we shut it down was I was getting
thousands and thousands of Russian emails that were signing up for my website.
This is what you remember that Jamie, this is years ago.
This is like three years ago. Okay. Jaime and fucking fat,
like tens of thousands of Russian email addresses.
We're signing up like similar addresses. It was something like the Ira,
something like the Internet research agency,
which does that which is responsible for all those fake pages on Facebook and
Google and Instagram and all that shit.
And they were signing up for websites and that had message boards and then they
would jump on and pretend that they were whatever the fuck they were. Right.
Pretend that they were a social justice warrior,
pretend that there was black lives matter and they just start fights,
start arguments. And it was like, wow, this is fascinating. And then when it,
when it also happened and that it happened with Facebook and it became a big
part of the election,
you realize like this is like a concerted effort to use these platforms to
wiggle. So when your jack or your, whoever runs,
you have to look at that and go, okay, hello. Fuck, do we manage that?
I mean if we're in a free speech,
we should just let these people manipulate everybody. Let it be wild, wild west.
How can, I mean,
it's when you have these people that are working for the Russians or even people
that are working on the left that are trying, I mean,
if there really is someone that's doing that to the Donald,
a subreddit on Reddit, what do you do?
If you're in the free speech, you're supposed to allow that, right?
You could just create a metric, you know, or,
or some sort of mechanism that red flags in account publicly. Right.
But I think this is where it gets slippery, right?
Because then you're talking about an algorithm,
you're talking about manipulating search results.
You're talking about not that route. What I'm saying, I mean, not that rough,
but this is where it goes, right?
If you just keep managing the content instead of like someone like, like Gab,
where they just let the content flow free. But obviously you go there,
there's a lot of dumpster fires, man. It's like fucking chaos or do that.
Oh yeah. Absolutely not is going to be perfect. Right. You know, um,
I think whenever you see a bad, that's good, right?
Oh yeah. Uh, bad is a, a,
a portal to good. It is, uh,
an opportunity to fix something because at some point that problem was going to
emerge, right? It just emerged now. So it's like, Oh wow, okay,
here's this problem. The solution, every problem lies within the problem.
So technically there is no problem.
So let's just go ahead and solve this problem and we'll want to the next
one. You know? But I love problems. I love solving problems.
I think it's really fun. Uh, so when I see a problem, I go, hmm, okay, let's,
let's think about this. And sometimes it's not a one person job, you know,
it's a whole committee and a whole bunch of minds have to get together.
So when I look at the conservative community, I think about like, you know,
aren't you have all these minds but are your minds working to complain or your
mind's working to solve the problem.
And it seems like the minds aren't working to solve the problem,
to work in a complaint, right? So, for example, um,
during the early 20th century or early 19 hundreds is do with this newspaper
super-popular in New York. And, uh, he puts some, uh,
an inflammatory things about a certain family in New York City. And, uh,
all the department stores boycott the newspapers. He has no advertisers.
So they did that to put him out of business.
And this gentleman takes the space and gives it to the proletariat or the,
you know, small business guys in the area.
And he gives them full front page ads, right?
Stuff that the department stores couldn't buy.
And then what happened was after the, the newspaper got,
is circulating like that to department stores,
department stores came back and they said, Yo, all right, all right, fine, fine.
We'll, we'll pay. We'll come back. And, and he said, no, I'll need you anymore.
You know, I have people that can do this. I can do this with the people.
And His newspaper was successful until the day he died.
So when I look at that example that was able to thrive in 19, uh, you know,
20 or something or 1910 and whenever it was, I look at it and I'm like,
if this guy just stood on his laurels and didn't bow,
you know, then why can't we do it as a nation or as a team? You know? Um,
I think it's very possible to, uh, so for example, like when we look at gap,
right? There's a new competitor, I'm not gonna mention the name,
but it's like they,
whoever was the establishment created this alternative platform to compete with
Gab on other workers. You know what I mentioned the name now screwed them,
really puck them. Um, what's bad about them? Their establishment, right? Oh,
so, so when I look at, so establishment is created another free speech platform,
allegedly, allegedly,
they're just going to collect the data on these people and, you know,
sell it off. What makes you think that intuition, you know,
hoteps have been told you, you know,
[inaudible] that should be, well, we got a shirt.
Hoteps been told you you that's how show, Oh man, I'll go to this.
I show every Thursday, 8:00 PM eastern time. Um, so yeah. Um, you know,
uh, I, I can, I can kind of,
I've been calling a lot of these shots and a lot of these things and you know,
there's just certain things that, you know, I'm a tech startup founder, right?
Right.
So it's certain things I can see within a business that the average person can't
see. And I'm like, God, that doesn't make sense. That doesn't look right.
And when you need to see, uh, you know, as a tech startup,
it's really hard to get going right at first, but when you see like MSNBC, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, and it's just like, how'd you get all these coverage that fast?
Who Do you know? You know what I mean?
And then you start seeing the influencers that are going over there and pushing
them like, oh, these are all established. I see what's going on.
What you didn't want,
you didn't want an alternative platform that you didn't control.
Hmm. Okay. So they creating an alternative platform that they can control.
They can control air quotes. Alternative, correct. Yeah.
Well I think the writing is on the wall, right? If they look at the,
there's only one Twitter, there's only one Instagram.
There's only one youtube and those are giant.
And Facebook is basically the only thing like that. Right?
I mean there's really no competitor to Facebook in that space.
I mean, this is four of them. They're all trash. Let's be honest.
Oh my goodness. This all trash. Hotep is going off Facebook trash.
I've been saying that for like the past decade. Facebook's trash.
I stopped using Facebook a decade ago. Right. If I used it,
it was just like forced, you know, I use it as a publishing outlet.
I want to put this tour dates or something like that.
I put it on Facebook around engage. Right, exactly. Yeah. So you know, I can,
I can respect that. I don't use Instagram.
I lifted it months ago when of our Congo off the platform,
a bunch of conservative got kicked off the platform. I'm like,
I don't need this shit neither. So I left.
And also to keep your account just in case. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah,
it's bookmarked. Um, you know, I've got an automated Bot.
I'm going to set up and order all that stuff. Yeah. So, you know,
FDA's platforms, we don't need them. They're not that great.
If you look at the story on Instagram, Instagram was a, uh,
a lucky project. It was serendipitous, right. Basically what happened was, uh,
some kids built a project, it was called Instagram.
They were working on a whole bunch of other things.
Some popular kids started using the platform.
It blew up and then they pass it on Facebook from the very inception. I said,
this is a very trash product product. It's just horrible. Horribly curated.
Right. It's so horribly curated that Facebook can't even monetize the platform
properly. Right. But that's a whole nother story.
But the platform itself and its functionality is stupid.
It's just popular. Well, you know,
what's weird is like replying to people and reading replies,
like went in the comments, like you can't even keep up with that. Nothing. No.
And you can't get all your notifications.
The notifications aren't curated properly. It's just,
it's like as if they don't care. Right? They don't care.
They don't care or is it that it got so big so quick and it's stuck in this
format? You'd have to kind of reformat the way it's they don't care.
Don't think so. They don't care. They don't care if you,
if you want to build a product for your user, you can do that.
If you want to build a product for advertisers, you can do that.
They built the product for advertisers and not for users.
If they build it for users, you and I will be able to have a conversation on it.
Well isn't it originally, wasn't it text America? Was that the same thing?
Was Text America the original one?
That's the one where I have the picture of the prostitute. In the bathroom.
You mean like where you at text something to
you send a photo, you send a photo on a tablet.
It wasn't like I would go up to an internet website.
It would be like on a site like imagery or something.
Not like a feed where people would follow you like that was it. No.
There was a thing that you would follow. Okay.
That's where that picture came from. I know that,
but I didn't remember it being like a website or anything like that was back
when there was no applications man, because I took that from a flip phone.
The big deal. That's the difference. What kind of phone or like a smart phone?
Yeah. There was no smart phones back then.
And then you would have to go to a website to see all your photos.
So like you have a young Jamie page on text America and all the pictures that
you had taken, the first photos on Instagram, a lot of people were,
you'd be like, Shit. As a photographer, you'd be kind of like shit on.
If you weren't taking it with your iPhone only Mike and you were uploading DSLR
photos, you'd be like,
oh your fucking cheat and look at you likes that kind of Shit. Right.
But now it filters like some of these girls who look like cartoons,
they didn't even look like humans.
Hmm. I, you know, it comes down to is like, you know, I wish I could wholeness.
Right. So, you know, a lot of people told me and he was like, Yo,
you missing out on a lot of money on Facebook.
He missed out on a lot of Instagram or money on Instagram.
My homies a millionaire off of Instagram and Facebook advertising and he told me
about it. I'm like, Yo, I'm not in this for money bro.
I got a message to get across and I can't get it across on these platforms.
They suck. Right,
but are you going to have the colonias to come and say,
I'm choosing my laurels over. I'm choosing my morals over the money.
Cause it's a lot of people out here that are on the Facebook platform just for
money.
I spoke to a conservative influencer and a brother basically said,
I'm trying to feed my daughter, but the stuff he's putting out on Facebook,
he doesn't believe in. So he's just doing it for profits. 200 for profit. Ooh,
that's where it gets weird, right? He says,
then people are not going to believe. You want to say,
well I was doing that for money, but now I'm telling you the truth.
But these are, I'm talking about this,
these are the people that everybody believes.
These are the ones that have captured a large audience.
I mean, talking about, you know, type of money you can pull in on, on Facebook,
but you know, he literally says, you know, I'll go on Twitter,
I'll make one tweet and then they get like 2000 retweets and then, you know,
you know, I, you know, it's, his brain just blows up like that,
but it's because he, he knows the buzzwords, right?
He knows what to say to get the people going, I'll go that route.
You know what I mean? If I don't like Facebook, I'm not going to use,
if I don't like Facebook, I'm not gonna use Instagram. You know, I'm just gonna,
you know, stick with what I like.
I like Twitter and I told people in 2009 when I go in there, I'm Twitter.
You know, I deal in marketing.
So I always say focus on one channel when it comes to social media and just one
channel, unless you have the staff to manage. Well,
Twitter is how I found out about you and that's all I found out about your
videos and I found out what you're going to watch your videos and if,
if that didn't exist
and the, the portal for the video, you're putting your videos on youtube, right?
I mean, what, how else would someone get their message out if you, if you,
if you think that these platforms are all trash, if they didn't exist,
I wouldn't find out about you.
Twitter's great. Twitter's great member. I'd like,
I've never mentioned Twitter do study. You said all of them are trashed,
but all of them, except it's what Twitter, it's what is my baby man?
I love Twitter. What do you like so much about Twitter? It's uh,
it's, it's, it's, it's a perfect platform to crowd source information,
number one. Right? Um, like you said, without Twitter, we,
I wouldn't be sitting here right now.
I couldn't have a got you on Facebook and Instagram.
That would've never happened. Maybe Instagram, some of a friend,
most of it is like, Hey, one of my friends says, check out this guy.
This guy's cool. This guy's interesting. Right?
Maybe you should talk to this guy. Okay. That's how it usually happens.
And then I'll go to your page and I checked it out and I saw a lot of
interesting conversations you were having and saw some videos.
Well the thing is Instagram doesn't allow you to see in my heart,
they don't allow you to see in the sole Twitter.
I can really connect with people. How come you can't do that in Instagram?
The algorithm man, you know you, oh you mean because it hides stuff and stuff.
Yeah. Once you developed a good following, it doesn't really matter.
People would go to your page. But how awful for you.
But how often can you post on Instagram? How often can you post with, well,
you can't do it like Twitter where you can just do it every couple of minutes.
See what I'm saying? So if I wanted to,
I could go from deep to where my middle aged white women at.
Right in 15 minutes time. Right. You know,
I can take you deep and then I could make you laugh. You know what I mean?
And I can share, you know, something else, I can share my video.
And you get that photos on Twitter, just like you could have on Instagram,
really wanted to go live.
And so Twitter is great at how they curate. Um,
the live feature. It lands at the top of your phone on mobile. Right?
It's beautiful. Like, like they, like they get product, you know,
I don't feel like Instagram gets product. Um, but Twitter is, you know,
matter of fact, this is a great time that I brought you my book.
I thought that was McDonald's or Burger King. What is he eating? That car? Just,
this is my book right here. Twitter marketing. I brought that for you.
Retails on, um, how to build a cult like following. Yeah.
And that's basically all my secrets on how I got on the Joe Rogan experience.
I want to try, I'm trying to remember who told me about you.
I want to give someone that you have the credit. I, uh, well, you know, they,
people said to me, you know, you should go on Joe Rogan.
And so I retweeted it and then, um,
it started as far as storming your mentions and then you follow me and then I
read to you the guy followed you because someone told me though,
I'm trying to remember who the fuck it is. Oh, somebody, you know,
somebody I knew. Okay. The guy's like a serendipitous thing like that.
I don't even know if they'd seen you post that you're trying to get on the
podcast. I think someone had just contacted me and said, hey,
check out this guy. Shit. Oh, I have watched some of the youtube conversations.
You just look like you were having a good time,
but you're talking about serious shit. Yeah, it's, it's, you know,
so I've got kids. So, um, when I,
when I teach my kids, it's always through entertainment. You know,
if I can't make my kids laugh while I'm doing my lecture everyday when they come
home from school or I try to do everyday, there's a lecture way in for them.
I'm going to talk
about something real in life. How many kids? You have? Three of my daughters.
16 and my boys are Ra 2010. I have twin boys, a Dallas,
Phoenix and Sydney. Um, they're all named have to cities. Um,
so everyday they come home. I have a lecture waiting for them,
but when I prepare my lectures for them,
I always figure out how am I gonna make them laugh? Cause my son Dallas,
he's a very linear in thinking I could lecture and I'll sit there and listen to
every single word. The other two are like me. They'll just like zone out.
So your twins not are they're identical twin fraternal fraternal. Yeah.
So his brother and his sister are just like me with all tune out and going to la
La land and started getting weird when you have two kids that were born at the
exact same time, they're are twins,
but yet they're totally different and he looked different that so one's Brown's
game. One's lightskin whoa. Both come out of the box at the same time too.
You hit it, you know, it's a crazy dynamic. The bursts, headaches and nuts, man.
Yeah. Their personalities are very different.
One of the thing that trips me out the most about having kids is how,
how does they are their own little person out of the fucking box? Yeah.
Like you influenced them a little. You teach them,
you can give them morals and ethics and you can set a good example. But boy,
they come with their own unique set of ingredients Yeti. Do you any do.
And uh, you know, I don't, I don't try to change that.
All I try to do is push them in that direction. Like whichever way you're going,
I'm just going to try and assist that, you know,
I don't try to like bring you back this way. So my son Dallas, he likes to draw,
you know, and I'm like, alright, well here's some youtube videos, tutorials,
do it every day. You know, my son Phoenix is like,
I want to have my own comic book. I'm like, we'll start writing it.
And he starts writing his comic book and then he comes in,
he asked me questions and I help them, we share in a Google doc and we just,
we just do the damn thing. You know what I mean? That's cool. Yeah,
they're little startups. So you kinda just gotta you just gotta feed them,
you know? That's a good way of looking at it. Yeah. Um, you know,
you've got a wardroom man and just let them grow.
I think sometimes we try to prune them too much. Well,
you definitely see that a lot with people that are too,
they're just way too heavy handed with their kids and the kids just always
resisting. Oh yeah. They're just constantly to get the fuck away from me, man.
Necessary. It's unnecessary. It's unproductive.
And you're going to develop a rift between you and your kids. Yeah. So,
so this story I always tell is, um, you know, when,
when you black and you go into a supermarket,
you get that talk like Ben not going, Hey Ben, not touching it.
Don't ask for nothing. Right. So, um, you know, that's how I grew up.
A lot of us grew up.
So when I go into the supermarket or I went into the supermarket this one time
and my son is a Phoenix, my twin,
he's running around in the supermarket and you know, I don't,
I try not to yell at my kids and all that stuff, right?
So I just tap his brother and sister on a show and I said, look at him,
look at him, look at him. And he look and, and we just started laughing at him.
So he turns around and goes like, why are y'all laughing at me?
So then I start imitating [inaudible] doing all that type stuff and he's,
so he's, I put the mirror in front of my, with the mirror and when he does that,
never again.
Yeah. Problem again. I didn't have to yell at him. I didn't have to hit him.
I had to cuss him out and I have to threaten them. That's great that, you know,
it's just, it's just basic psychology. Yeah.
That's one of the hardest things for people to do is see how other people see
them. And when someone sees you with humor and you look like a fool, like,
oh shit, that's me.
That is me is ugly. So you just gotta put your mirror. But you know, Twitter,
you know, I, I handle, I handle everything. Uh, you know,
I figure you can't change culture through lecture.
You change culture through entertainment.
What do you think about all this talk like Elizabeth Warren's talked about it
and some other candidates have talked about as mother politicians have talked
about breaking up these big companies, breaking up Facebook.
It's too big breakup, Google breakup, Twitter. What do you think about that?
Well, um, I think we have to study what happened to standard oil.
What happened to standard oil standard oil. They uh,
broke it up and it became, uh, Exxon, Chevron,
Texaco, uh, I think BP,
don't quote me on that one, but does anybody have brand loyalty to gas?
Does anybody like, dude, I'm a Chevron man. They create those, those cards,
right? Those Oh, loyals. You guys cards. Oh, okay. Yeah. Yeah.
That's how they created a loyalty program. Here it is.
The evolution of standard oil. Jamie pulled it up on the screen. Yeah,
there you go. Wow. So standard oil was too big. Yeah. Like fuck this place,
right? We have to move it around a little bit. 1911 standard oil of Kentucky,
1911 they did this, right. So, so if you look at it, it's broken up into,
I think it says 34 right? 34 companies, right? So you start them on a,
on the left, right. And then as you go, what do you see?
You see a consolidation, don't you? You see these emerges. Yeah.
So when you break up a monopoly,
you're not really breaking up with not monopoly.
What you're doing is you're creating a divide and conquer dynamic. So it's like,
okay, I'll let my brother control this one.
My sister control that with my cousin controls us.
And you actually corner the market.
So breaking up with not believe isn't exactly a good thing in that case.
Yeah. In that case, and I think we'll see the same thing with Google.
If we break up Google or what you are going to do is just have little
subsidiaries or little satellite things that will just control a certain segment
under a different name, which would make it harder to track back to its source.
So I, you know, when I say, you know, break up monopoly,
I think that the establishments like, yeah, come on, break me up baby.
You think so? Oh Dan, I don't think they want to lose any control.
I certainly know like Facebook does.
It's not using controlled Zuckerberg forever, right?
Aren't they trying to get rid of him?
The board members don't like as a date claim, but that robot Outta here,
let's look away drinks water, right? He doesn't look like a robot.
We drink water in front of Congress. But isn't that socialism? That's socialism.
When you don't,
the government comes in and tells you what you can do with your cooperation.
Yeah. That's socialism. So,
so what I feel is like the powers that be are pushing socialism or like we can
use this as an excuse to Evel dre corporations
and you know, Blah Blah Blah, blah, blah.
And can start controlling this internet space.
So the Internet space is now communist.
I'm of the opinion though that if we believe in freedom of speech and you create
something that's so big that it's essentially a town square,
which is what I think these platforms are [inaudible] you. If you ban people,
especially if you ban people from Shit, like learn to code,
like things that don't make any sense. Yeah.
There's people that getting banned for some pretty ridiculous ideas. Yeah.
That as soon as you start doing something like that,
you are going against the fundamental ideas that this country has found done.
Absolute freedom of speech.
I think it's incredibly important that if you have someone saying something that
you think is wrong or is hurtful,
there should be an avenue where people can examine that and talk about it and
combat it with good speech with speech. That makes sense.
Yeah. Well, you know, a couple of years ago, last year, I forget now,
it was about a couple of years ago, um, I was lambasted for, uh,
defending white nationalists and you know, when they first got d platforms,
some of them got deep platform with just white nationalist period. I'm like,
well, if this is how these people feel, let's listen to them.
It's listen to their gripes. What are they mad about? Right?
And then people like, oh, how could you, these people that are racist.
And I'm like, I don't care if they're racist. Like that doesn't affect me.
Right? Like I'm not asking them for a job so they can't be racist towards me.
You know what I mean? But, um, when you have these,
these groups that people call fringe,
I feel like the people that are fringe are the tests for freedom of speech.
It's not the people in the middle,
it's the fringe groups on the outside if they don't have freedom of speech.
Everybody in the middle school group. So I stood up and I was like, Yo,
let these dudes talk. Like, stop doing that. Like, like, you know, I don't care,
you know, if they're racist or whatever, people call me names.
But then now you see it coming down and we lost, you know, Louis Farrakhan, e.
Dot. D platform. He lost his verification, you know, and it's like this,
was there anything specifically that he said that allowed him to do that?
Or did they just make a sweeping cause they got rid of Milo.
They got rid of Gavin McInnes.
They got rid of a bunch of people that were on Instagram and Facebook that they
hadn't d platform.
But it didn't seem like there was anything that happened that caused them to do
that.
It seemed like they just made some sort of a decision that I think was probably
based on preparing for the 2020 election.
Absolutely. So, so what I think what happened was, uh, the, uh,
the banning of Louis Farrakhan is just a theory, but they were like, all right,
if we ban these conservatives,
the conservative crowd is going to just go apeshit. Right.
But if we throw him Louis Farrakhan,
it'll kinda settle things down a little bit. Cause it will look like we're fair.
I think you're exactly right. Yeah. So I'm like,
so that's what they did and like, Hey, let's throw him in there now, you know,
smooth things over. That's exactly what I thought when I saw it. Yeah. Yeah.
I was like, this seems weird. Yeah. It's like they have to justify like, no,
we got rid of him too, you know? Yeah. Yeah. It's a,
it's a strange
time because there's,
even though there is gap and there's mines and there's is a couple of other
startups,
they're trying to make their way into the Jordan Peterson one and there's
nothing that really stands out. And once someone starts, once a,
a giant group of people starts using something, unless it's like, what's,
what's hilarious is when they, one of them vanish like my space.
How fucking badly did they manage my space because my space had it all.
They had everybody and then it just fucking died and still around.
But now it's like some fringe music publishing platform. It's very weird.
You know, still exists.
But what Twitter is right now and what Facebook is right now and what Instagram
is right now, it seems like there's no real competitors per se,
specifically youtube. There's no real competitors
because, because when, you know,
I don't want to dog pile on, you know, mines or Gab or anything.
But the problem is when you build a social network and is why will not build a
social network at least not in to the next 10 years.
You have to understand that you can't build a social network that mimics another
one. Hmm. It has to bro. It has to be different.
That's why snap is still here, right? Snap is inside a certain demographic.
That's my daughters, you know, generation, right?
That's them right there on snap. So when you build these things,
you really have to sit down and say like, you know, what's the,
what are we going to focus on? Like with mines, right? You Poach Physios,
you post photos and then how do the photos appear? Right?
So when I look at minds, minds is my Instagram. When you,
when you look at minds on mobile, that the fonts really small. So it's like,
I can't read this, so I'm just going to use this for photos.
Can I put the photos? It pops up, right? So it's like,
is mind's going to go that route? Or they're going to go the video route.
Are they going to go the tweet route?
You got to pick one and then grow from there. If you look at Twitter,
Twitter didn't have all these Fitch features in the beginning.
You just had tweaked. That's it. There was no threats. You know what I mean?
None of that. So you have to start at your core, but when you,
the other problem they do is they try to build these social networks, um,
completely robust, right? With all the bells and whistles of the giants.
Nah, Bro,
you got to start small and slim and then let your audience tell you what the
next feature is. So what would you, if you were going to start one up,
what would it be? Or do you know? I'd information now it's not,
I don't want to give it out in information. I think information should be free,
but you know, I, I hate,
I hate the idea that people want to create social networks. I'm like,
they exist.
Let's use the ones that exist and let's just figure out how to make them better.
Right? If you need to do that,
then those have so much power because they can dictate who's on and who's not
on, right? So what you do is when you have something like a Twitter,
you use your Twitter, uh, to congregate your minds, right?
But then you're, you know, you're, your bills of the world,
your, your Andrew Toby's of the world have to listen to the community and,
and then cure rate their product around what the community needs. Right.
Andrew Toba figured out what the dissenter when he found out, oh,
the Internet is blocking comments. So then he created, you know,
you can comment on anywhere on the internet and then Google chrome smashed it.
Right. As I get that Outta here. Yeah. Why did they do that?
What was the justification for getting rid of that? They want a sensor.
It didn't want to sensor inflammation.
Is that what they want to do or they want to keep a competitor from using their
platform and profiting off of it. That's how I looked at it.
I looked at it from a marketing or a business perspective. Nah,
I ain't worried about his name because it can be, but if it becomes huge,
I mean anything can become huge if it's useful. Yeah.
That seemed useful to me that they were going to be able to comment on anything
and you'll have like a little link and if you use gab you can comment on
anything that comes up. Yeah. Yeah. You can look at it like that. I don't,
I feel like, you know, they, their budgets are so huge. They're, they, you know,
their cash reserves is so huge that they're not worried about competition at
all. You know, what they're worried about is, uh,
controlling thought and that's their primary goal and control thought,
right. For the betterment of the ruling class. And that's,
to me, that's, that's the end all be all of it all. Um, but you, uh,
these, these, you know, the, these, these people that create tech products,
like when we create coin bits app or for example, my app, Jeff Fatah's,
Jeff midsize do you can only do one thing on derivatize.
The only thing you can do is, uh,
save a video or g or Jif from Twitter.
I always call it a Gif. Is it Jeff? I think it's Jeff. I've never,
I don't think I ever hear anybody say it. Gift could be correct.
Could be correct. Do you know what he called Jamie? I call it Gif.
If Jeff Gif. Jeff is peanut butter. Alright. Jeff has been great,
but our app does one thing right.
And people love it.
When I first came on as a co founder, this app did more than that.
And when it did more than that, it didn't do as well as it does now.
What it used to do, uh, we had incentives, uh, to uh,
share the app. You could edit g, uh, gifts. Uh, you could,
um, put text on them, um, uh,
crop them all types of like had an editor in there. So I was like, Yo,
take this editor, toss it out all, we had a keyboard and you know,
it still has a keyboard,
but I was like took some of the functionalities and I just started taking stuff
out and just like, get this Outta here, get this out.
I get necessary slim it down. Right. As soon as we slimmed it down, we chained,
gave it a new face. Boom. I revenue quadruple what's again,
tell people get it. Yeah. [inaudible] do you have a tight there? Yes.
Jamie's got it. Yeah. G, F, r. I. T. I. Z. E,
the ultimate Twitter gift downloader. Yeah. Yeah. And this is,
this thing's about to be super huge. Uh,
we have a gallery coming soon and that's going to be awesome.
I'm going to be perfectly curated.
I'm not speak to my partner Simona's morning about that.
This is one of the fun things about Twitter when someone says something stupid
and then you look at all the gifts underneath it. Memes and gifs. Yeah.
So we empower people like black twitters on our app.
So whenever there's a new video out,
you know it's something funny happens and you use an as a reaction.
So we on Ios, there's no way to save it. Now you can with our app.
But app only does one thing and everybody's, and they love it. Right?
That's, that's the core of the business.
What's the core of minds? What's the core of gap?
What's the core feature? Does anybody know? There is not a core feature? Yeah,
I wouldn't, I would say just something as an alternative to traditional media.
You see what I'm saying? So there is no uniqueness where there is no uniqueness.
You can't compete. You have to first create uniqueness. Mm.
Or, or fill a need.
There is no need for me to be on these other platforms. Well,
the problem is when you get on those other platforms and there's no one,
there you go, Huh? Let me go back to Twitter real quick. Yeah.
And that's why I say when you build a social network, the,
before you build a network, you have, I mean, before you build the platform,
you have to build a network.
What's interesting if you go back to like 2003 when my space was king and then
you imagine what the world would be like 16 years later,
no one would have saw this coming.
No one would have saw all these social media platforms and that it's used as a
way of breaking news now. I mean,
especially in places that don't have real objective news.
So if you're in some country that's some war torn country and some horrible shit
is going down, you see the news breaking on Twitter before anywhere.
Oh yeah. Really interesting. Oh yeah.
That's what I tell people like screw Facebook and Instagram. The news breaks on,
on Twitter, you know, by the time, you know, by the time I show all my friend,
my friend shows me a video. I'm like,
I saw it on Twitter like two weeks ago Bro.
Cause he's on Facebook or he's on Instagram. Right.
So it's like how do you market a product or market yourself when you're two
weeks behind? [inaudible] is two weeks behind on Instagram though.
I get a lot of shit on Instagram too. Like you're Joe Rogan. Yeah.
So it's different, you know, it depends on who you're surrounded by, right?
So when we talk about network, it's like, you know,
who are the people connected to? Are you following?
Who's who you interacting with? But I get like, mom, that's not true.
I was gonna say, I get like most of the fucked up videos of news,
stories of bad things that are happening in the news come to me on Instagram.
But I think send it to
you. Yeah, but I think it's even,
I think it's even with Instagram and Twitter [inaudible] sending me things.
Well you didn't one when you're Joe Rogan, even ever your hotep Jesus,
like a people will say to me, how do you know so much? I'm like, Yo,
my followers, like yeah, books and links and stuff like that.
Like they're just sending it to me. You know, sometimes I ask them sums,
I don't, but they're volunteering information. Um,
so when you're in that position, you know you can afford it. But when,
so the key to marketing is this, you know,
you've got your four p's of marketing, but the key to marketing is relevance.
If what you're talking about is irrelevant, nobody's paying attention to you,
right? Yeah.
So the only thing that makes somebody platforms relevant is the juxtaposition to
the big tech giants. You remove the tech giants. Are you still relevant?
What makes you relative?
Right, right, right. That's where a lot of people that do content,
whether they're um, you know, podcasters or whatever,
they probably should be thinking about developing an email list and putting
things on the website,
having something available independently of these big platforms.
I've been thinking about that a lot lately doing what,
but if something that independent of these big platforms where like if you mean
you see all these people that have gotten deep platforms and I don't think I'm
at the risk of that,
but if I didn't think these people were just a few years ago as the climate
shifts and people get more and more radical with this idea of d platforming,
I think it becomes like a game of like shooting ducks.
People get excited about it.
They like taking people out whether it makes sense or not.
And I think there's a lot of that going on where people are calling for people
to be TD platform just because they disagree with them.
And so far these big tech companies have resisted some of it,
but not, not enough of it for my taste.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, my boy Alex Jones,
they got him out of here. I think, you know,
if I was Alex, my ego would be so huge after getting the platform.
Well when we did a podcast together after he was d platform,
it was one of the biggest podcasts of all time. But again,
like 16 million youtube videos or something. That's your high use.
Me and my youtube did not demonetize that one. We let them know in advance,
just heads up. Alex Jones is coming on and then they just took that money.
Yeah.
It's interesting how it works, right? Like what they choose to d platform with.
They don't choose to, you know, it's um, I mean,
I don't like the argument that they're, they're doing it for our good. I don't,
I don't think they are.
Oh, who, who, who, who made them? God. Who made them, you know,
mom and said this is good for you and they should be forced to follow the first
amendment. No. What do you think they should be forced to do? Nothing. Nothing.
Nothing. I think,
I think they should be operating in a manner that doesn't hurt earth. You know,
it doesn't hurt their nature. Right.
If they're polluting or doing something at harm, somebody specifically,
um, then yes. Right. So if they become a giant monopoly,
just because they're better than everything else that's available,
like youtube has become, then they run the show.
But there is always the underground. Yeah. Look at hip hop. Right?
There's always been an underground hip hop comedy as well. Comedy as well,
you know, so you got dudes, you know,
so I was talking to somebody that day and we tell them our consciousness,
conscious hip hop and do say, oh, there's no money in conscious hip hop.
I'm like, what? I'm like Pharrell,
much tours consistently dead pres dead Prez towards aid system.
Never had any mainstream attention at all. The only,
the closest thing they had the mainstreams when they were Dave Chappelle's block
party. Okay. That was about it. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's like you don't need mainstream, we don't need me stream. You know?
Here's the thing with mainstream, when you get mainstream, you're that bitch.
Now you got to play by the rules, you know, and,
and once you break those roles, you get deep platforms,
which you need to do is you need to focus on building your own platform so they
can't touch you when you get to a certain place. Say if you're helping me out,
I called you and Hotep teases me. I need some help. Right?
What do I do with this platform? This platform right here. Right here. Oh Dang.
That's why didn't they come down on us? A I,
so you got to self host it probably on blockchain. Um, I would definitely a bit,
shoot, just locked. Uh, how do I sell posted on blockchain? I don't know.
Blockchain is one of those words that I use that I don't really understand.
Me Too. I just say because it's a cool buzzword. That's a great word.
It's just like, sounds like if you each,
some dude is a tech guy like yourself as a tech startup and you start talking
about block chain. I go, Oh yeah, I'll just nod my head. Yeah,
blockchain is my friend uploaded a MP3 to the BSV network maybe.
Okay. It's just very confusing and I was trying to ask him, I'm like,
now that it's on there. Yeah. Wow. How do people going to get it?
And like he wanted to just be like the first on there, which he is or whatever.
I might not be BSV. I might be speaking your rapper friend. Yes. Okay. Hey,
well he's like, he's ahead of him. He's ahead of this. He's just like,
come on some of this bitcoin stuff, so yeah,
but that's where it's at and I was like talking to him for that.
Like he's almost my Guinea pig. Like, all right, you did it.
How you figured it out. Now how do I get a three hour podcast on there?
How are people going to get it? It's like it's not figured out yet.
People are definitely working on it and that every day there's been advances.
I just don't know. I don't know how it's going.
I mean, you could build your own cloud. Yes. You know, build your own cloud and,
and self host and you know, you, you know what else you could do.
You could connect with all your other celebrity buddies,
pull your resources together and just build a competitor and then own this space
and be like, I'm the new youtube, it's called Rogan tube now. Hmm.
You know what I mean?
You could do that and then everybody just runs to your platform. I'd support it.
I'd have to have a way better name.
How do you do that without using Google's cloud services?
What do you need to do is by Vimeo,
Vimeo was dying on the vine that pitches barely alive. What's so, so like,
so these questions that you asked, right?
Like there's like they own the internet kind of almost. So these,
these questions that you ask, I don't know. I don't. Cool. Right, right.
So what we do is we get the best tech minds in the building and we ask them the
questions, hey, answer this. It's not like they can't answer.
I'm sure they're going to find solutions. There's always a way, you know,
just got to put the right minds in the room.
[inaudible] you know the right minds in the room and the right people that are
influencers that can get the word out. Yeah, you have to,
you've got to follow the yard drop on a Napkin rule. And you know,
when you put the drop on the Napkin, it spreads out, right? So you gotta figure,
you know, who's your network and then you know,
maybe build like 12 people around and make sure that these people are linked,
you know, based upon interest. Right?
So then it starts at those interest points or affinities and then the next tier
grows out from there. But as long as that tight knit group,
all right, so problem with gap, right? It's all people say, oh, it's all Nazis.
Right? Well that's that tight knit
crew and just and tight knit group of Nazis sell a shirt says that
it's not just that though it's probably just that a hundred regular folks in one
Nazi, that Nazi becomes the defining factor of the group. Right.
There's Nazis in there.
Right. So you know, it's not that at all,
but there is a strong white nationalist movement that first gravitated over
there. If he didn't have that, there would be no gap. Do you think so?
I mean, I don't think so at all. Really? Yeah. Like whoa, whoa.
Who would go there? People that got kicked off of Twitter,
but the only people that got got kicked off Twitter in the early days with white
nationalists. Well, who's the first people like w if you go back to them again,
if, yeah, Gavin McInnes is an interesting character.
Not identify as a white nationalist. No, he does not.
And his wife is actually native American. He's,
he's just made some sense
stupid choices. Right? Well,
I mean like baked Alaska was kind of thrown into that. Yeah.
But he just like a meme maker. He's like, God makes funny memes.
It's very funny. Right? Very entertaining. Um,
but I think it comes down to WHO's dangerous or,
yeah. Well,
the proud boys became a dangerous idea because once you have a group and you
don't control who joins the group,
then assholes can join your group and then your group is made out of assholes
and you're like, well, I didn't want it to be assholes. But what you'll,
you'll let anybody in if you let anybody in a group. Yeah.
I just have a joke about vegans about that.
The problem with any group is the same.
Like if you get any group of a hundred people,
if you're in a room with a hundred people,
what's the odds that one of them is going to be a fucking idiot? Well,
it's a hundred percent one of them's going to be a fucking idiot.
If you have 300 million people,
you're going to have by odds 3 million fucking idiots. Right.
And the joke was a lot of them are vegans. Yeah. Yeah. It doesn't, it's not,
there's anything wrong with vegans. It's Wa with a group.
And people just identify,
they get in that group and this is my group and I'm here to represent.
And then it's just dummies.
The thing with the proud boys is the ruling elite are afraid of men. You know,
it's a huge soy boy movement coming down at Gunn and put down a pipe, right?
I mean soy everywhere. If anybody's listening right now,
everybody that's listening right now, soy is bad for you. It's not good.
It is very bad. It's processed nonsense. Estrogen. Oh yes. Well, it,
it uh, activates the phytoestrogens. No,
it has Actify phyto extractions that attack the endocrine endocrine gland
system.
Now when you look at the endocrine gland system of people in the spiritual
world,
endocrine gland system is the physical manifestation of the so-called shockers.
Right now at the heart shock,
where what we have is called the thymus gland and the diamonds Glen is the one
that controls your sexual maturity.
And when you have an endocrine gland disrupter,
your sexual maturity is affected.
So a man who would ordinarily, like women now likes,
you see what I'm saying?
Wouldn't you have to massive quantities of soil for that? Take place.
That's that subjective based upon your biological structure. Right?
I always think of it as more as like a fun thing to say. I don't think you know,
well he was a total fool. You turn into a bitch. Well here's the thing,
you can't go in the grocery store and find something that doesn't have. So
when you go look at your cheeses or your crackers, it was the say soy Lecithin,
soy and everything. So yeah, you were right. Uh,
they use it as Philip for some meats. So the whole Vegan movement, right?
You go and you go get your, your, your, your Vegan Burger Burger. Yeah. Right?
Uh, a lot of these burgers are soy based.
A lot of them are plant based for sure plant based oils. Right?
But so it's not good for you. Right.
And then you also look at the links between soil and cancer,
but that's a whole nother story.
But when you have something that's disrupting your so called shock Chris,
you can see how you can start affecting an entire population of people, right?
You start affecting their development at an early age. And then, you know,
you got these men who are, uh, acting like women who can't even, you know,
control their wives. You got some men out here that, uh,
let another man sleep with their girlfriend. Right. And, and, and, oh dear.
I don't know about here. We'll just say it out here. Well, when I say out here,
I mean it's everywhere in the world. Yeah. Yeah.
But isn't it just people just kinky in a weird shit? Well,
no, I don't think so. No. Wait, what do you think it is? I think it's pushed.
I think a doubletree's is highly pushed. Yeah. By who?
The ruling elite ruling class. I want to say really,
because they're not elite to sit around and go, you know what we need to do?
We need to push the Boucher. Well, when you look at, uh,
the degradation of a Russia right before the Bolshevik revolution,
what they do is they come in first, uh, with alcohol, right?
So they purchase hops and your barley and he produced alcohol.
Then what they do is they sell to alcohol to the farmer on credit cause he ain't
got no money. Right. Cause he'd been drunk.
He hasn't been producing a crops like he should. He falls into credit,
he falls into debt when he falls into the debt, he's now a slave to the land.
He wants old now and I can sell a whatever I want to his population or give this
population whatever I want because they are now technically my slave.
But in order to rule a nation of people,
you have to destroy morality. You have to destroy integrity. So you,
you feed them drugs, alcohol and sex,
and then tear apart the family.
Do you think that that's just a natural progression of people's Slovenly
instincts or do you think that some sort of a grand plan have a slovenly
instinct? Some people do. Yeah. I think some people are lazy in,
some people are weak and some people are greedy and some people just,
they lean towards,
they lean towards just pleasure without sacrifice and discipline because it's
easy and they just lay in bed and jerk off.
I don't think anybody's telling them.
I don't think there's any sinister government manipulating their strings that
makes them watch porn all day. I think they just,
yeah, it actually, you know Instagram is a gateway to porn.
Instagram. You can't go on Instagram without looking at some booty, right? Yeah,
but it's also
gateway to sunsets and people's kids and muscle cars.
Come on Joe. Cool. Shit. Ain't nobody going on Instagram as sunset.
People are going to Instagram and look at booty. There's a lot of that.
No Dog Yoga community has went from, hey,
check out my Bakasana to check out my backside pants.
Right? A lot of yoga pants, pigs, foodie, foodie booty. Just booty alone.
It's an industry. It is a giant industry on Instagram. Yeah,
so what happens is you wake up in the morning, you check your notifications,
then your homie tags you. Oh, look at this chick poem right now.
You have an erection. What's the first thing you do? You're like, oh,
let me go to my browser. Open an incognito browser and hit pornhub. Boom.
Now you're Outta here right now. Your Day's done.
You just depleted your yet energy. Right.
And this coming out of my book where I talk about, you know,
why you sent jerk off and all that stuff, but you right.
That you shouldn't jerk off. Yeah. Yeah. Never. Uh, well there's a calculation.
You have a jerk-off algorithm. Yeah. There's a jerk-off algorithm. Uh,
it's a created by the tower, the tower stuff, sexology.
And I think it's your age times to know your age divided by two times.
100. I forget what it is. It's in my book. I can't remember it. Uh,
but I got it from the towel. Right. Which is why I don't have it memorized.
Time Point Age Times 0.2. I think it's age times 0.2. Um,
and then it tells you how many days. Right? So at my age, I'm 38 now my age,
it's about seven and a half days between ejaculation to,
to maintain who I am. Really? Yeah. And Dam.
Yes. So our main strength is his balls, right? That's right.
It's every time you deplete yourself, you're not the same man anymore.
You lose your superpowers.
Now when you lose your superpowers to some, you know,
igg model, it's not even worthy.
Your orgasm doesn't feel the same as a natural interaction with a woman.
Right. You know what I mean? True. So you're wasting your superpower on,
on like a fictional fantasy.
So you're wasting a percentage of your vital energy, your,
your final energy as well as the proteins and minerals and zinc and magnesium
and all that stuff that you know is lost. Yeah. You know,
I think it's equivalent to like two New York strip steaks, eggs,
oranges and apples or something like that. Really? Oh yes. A lot of vitamins.
So I have a one on the size of the loads. You shoot though. No. Oh, you
should swallow. Whoa. Jesus ladies. I'm sorry.
That's why you should ingest it.
If the man is healthy because it's a, it's a full meal. It's a full meal.
It's a full meal of of nutrients that Amanda man loses.
There's a vial available that way. One of them has done studies.
We should to have a bet people have done like nutrition slash load studies.
Probably a startup out there like trying to do this right now,
calculate into an app.
Where's this conversation going now? What are we talking about?
Manipulating you, turning you into a soy boy? [inaudible] it's you.
You think there's actual, so this is where we differ.
You think there's actual manipulation taking place?
I think it's just natural instincts.
And then I think that people see it around them and then they cater to those
natural instincts and then they support those natural instincts.
But I think people have a natural instinct to be undisciplined and lazy and just
gratuitous and you know, yeah.
Dive into pleasure before sacrifice and commitment.
And so are we making excuses for not making excuses? I think it's a,
also the softness of the world we live in. Oh yeah.
Maybe we live in this incredibly easy to get buy in world, right?
You know where the poor people are fat. Yeah.
There's never been a time in history where poor people are fat. Yeah. Yeah.
That, that comes down to an actual food. Yeah. So-Called. It's certainly,
that is certainly the food is garbage, but it's also that,
well, there's this strange lack of discipline because it's not,
it's not necessarily I have to do is just show up to your job,
put in the least amount of effort you can without getting fired and you can
exist. Right. That didn't,
that didn't happen in the wild world when people are hunters and gatherers.
If you didn't put a hundred percent effort, if you didn't really struggle,
you didn't make it and you weren't a benefit to the tribe and they kicked your
ass out and you got eaten. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's how it's supposed to be. I do agree with that. Yeah. I do agree that, um,
discipline is, is, you know what we have to demand from people and you know,
um, but you know, your, your culture has to recognize about your Ian and,
and shun it and ban it and say like, Hey, you know, we don't want this here.
You know what I mean? Um, uh,
porn is readily available on Twitter and watch it right in your feet.
Sometimes I'm scrolling my feet.
Oh, that's a weird thing about Twitter, isn't it? That it's a giant platform,
but they allow porn. Yeah.
So you know when I had jack on with Tim Pool and I think Tim pulled,
didn't even know that porn was legal on it. Yeah. Right. So that I showed that.
Yeah. I have found that a little bit of information,
I don't know how accurate it is. Pools, Twitter use no.
On the ejaculation frequency. Yes. Recommended by the towels.
It said the most respected of the Tau theorists son Sim meow [inaudible] quoted
above recommends ejaculation no more than once every 20 days for men over 50
cheeses and no more than once every hundred days for men over 60 with that I
should be dead. Okay. And it has to do with it says no energy.
How am I getting everything done?
You're getting AIDS retarding hormones as you're about to ejaculate.
And then there's a level you want to keep before you ejaculate.
So balance what your before you excrete the hormones. That's what it's saying.
So tantra real quick. Yeah, I think so.
I think that's what it's supposed to come and turn on.
This is a level you can like optimize yourself.
[inaudible] lets people out of their fucking minds.
I'm trying to get rid of this shit. I,
I've always said that it helps you think because too many times with a man,
your, your mind is clouded by sexual desire.
If you could just jerk off and then you can think clearly.
I was telling her you saw a bit about it.
I say jerk off first then think about it like if you jerk off and then you want
to call a girl, it's because you love her.
You're not just trying to fuck you actually. Oh, like her as a human being.
You want to be around her.
You don't just be wanting to want to be around it for sex.
You actually really love her.
Yeah. I think there's a level of discipline. Right? So, um, yeah.
If you go about to make that, that risky text message, yeah.
You might want to shoot your low and assess it. Right?
I'm talking about like what the f I'm going to watch him fucking documentary.
Put that phone down. But that's for an undisciplined man. Yes.
So a discipline man's gonna say, no, I'm not gonna send this thirst trap,
you know, uh, this, this thirsty comment,
I'm going to stay disciplined in who I am because in order to get the woman I
have to stay away from the woman, you know,
in order to get the woman I have to stay away from the woman. Yeah. And, and,
and, and, and keeping your, you're at your vital man.
Energy for me keeps me like on edge.
Like I'm always like an animal, you know what I mean? Um,
because I want to release. Right. See what I'm saying. So, um,
what I do is I'll work up that energy and then channeling
into work. Hmm. I'll just immediately pull my laptop out and just bang out.
Cause it's like that frustration there and then just you got to release it that
way. Or I'll go running, I'll go work out what I'm saying.
But when I get around, women would have full sack.
Oh, I'm not the same as when I'm empty. Yes. And they see,
you can see the difference in how they attracted you. You sit up different,
your chest pokes out. When you're around other men,
you're like a little bit more edgy. Yeah. You know what I mean?
After you blow your load, you're kind of like chilled out. Yay. On competitive.
Noncompetitive. Yeah. Interesting. You hold on to that like fighters,
you know how to fight the fight. Mike Tyson never did that. My Tyson said, no,
I always like to come with me. Went to the Pothole Fund.
I'm not distracted and just shoot as low as and then beat the fuck out of
everybody. But I think Mike had a lot of extra loads.
I think if you had to guess,
it's the level he was just a ultra man. You know there was,
it was not a regular man.
This is a research published by the US National Library of medicine and National
Institutes of health found that after seven days of not a jacket waiting,
men's testosterone levels reached 145.7% of the baseline.
The interesting thing is that they didn't observe significant fluctuations from
the baseline. On days two through five.
The research also showed that the peak levels were at day seven. Yeah.
Risks Dow. It's actually Dow by the way. It's t a. O. It's a,
it's you say it as Dow, the Dow of g condo.
Risks of too frequent ejaculation.
When sex is performed with the recommended Dow frequency,
it becomes an inexhaustible source of energy like a well that never runs dry.
However,
when ejaculation frequency exceeds the capacity of the body to fully replenish
the seaman man could experience chronic fatigue, low resistance,
loss of sex drive, lots of focus and irritability.
Longterm excessive exam ejaculation can cause chronic low zinc conditions which
can cause chronic fatigue,
mental confusion and significant loss of sexual drive.
But what have your with a freak like that girl will.
Harris was talking about my friend will house was in here the other day and he
was saying he a human. He used to meet these girls and [inaudible].
Oh it's also considered harmful to ejaculate when ill drunk or go gorge with
food. Whoa. Here's the next, the next line. Oh which one?
Ejaculation control and discipline is not to be confused with the frequency of
sex. There are significant physiologic fizz.
What's that word? Physiological. There's supposed to be a period there. Oh,
physiological therapeutic benefits to having sex.
Frequent sex intercourse maintains a man's interest in the acts as well as his
capacity to continue indefinitely until his is fully satisfied.
So they're saying fuck, but don't come. Yes. Those
people out of their fucking mind. I come every time I fuck Yo. I, I used to uh,
try and get rid of this stuff. I used to fuck with three words.
I used to fuck with girls heads like that. We would not come. Yeah. Really?
They start crying. Wow. I had a girl like straight down and break up cry.
I can't please you. Is it me? Is it? Nah, I'm just like, no.
I just wanted you to be happy. How you feel? Feel good. Good.
Then I go when I hit the laptop and it just shows a musette. Oh really?
Oh Katie let at him.
He loved it because like nature wants them to get you to come. Yes.
Women only respected discipline, man. You don't. Once true,
once a woman can drop your defenses, she's no longer attracted to you.
If she can control you, she's not attracted to you.
A woman wants a man she could chase. In my book,
I talk about how women are the Apex Predator.
They're the ones that chase after sex. I mean, they can have sex endlessly,
right? Once we know it's like we're pretty much done. Like,
I mean you me a couple of minutes to recharge, but they could keep going.
You know what I'm saying? So they're, you know, technically like, you know,
freaks or whatever,
but just because she's undisciplined in her sexual energy doesn't mean you have
to be.
And if she feels like she has to go outside of the relationship to go get her
fixed, that's on her. That has nothing to do with you.
Your aspirations as a man are higher than sex.
A woman's role is to create life and support the man.
The man's role is to create the, the, the,
the afforded and the future of, of humanity. You know,
building things and innovating.
And it's true that a woman is not attracted to a guy without discipline.
Like Glenn men are lazy and weak. That is a giant turnoff to a woman.
But if a woman is hot, she could be pretty lazy. Absolutely.
They are the laziest people level. We don't care. Men don't see,
I don't care if a girl's lazy. She's hot. Well, a lot these, her body holds up.
Why she can get to the gym. I used to make girls work to get me, man. Real.
Yeah. Like, you know, I would say I'm, you know, I'm working on this project.
You know, I'm gonna send you a spreadsheet over. I need you to go organize it.
And if she'd say no, I just be like, all right,
well you're worthless to my life. I need,
I need somebody that's going to build with me. Right.
What if she's building her own shit? Fuck her shit.
Go pilcher shit. You know, if you need help, I'll help you. But you know,
she want to partner. Yeah. Want just a lover. That's what you're saying. No,
no. You want someone to help you. No. I want her to prove her worth. Whoa.
She gotta be worried to get me like, you know,
it's easy to get a girl then he's going get them. Good man. You know,
you only gonna find one hotel. Jesus in your life.
I could find a ton of you shorty. Wow.
You everywhere on Instagram after Joe Rogan is going to be,
they going to be everywhere. So,
but now some would say that that's a sexist generalization. Sure.
I don't care what the, I care. Look,
you can have that conversation like you and your platform. We can talk and I'll,
you know, if you want to call it sexist, it is what it,
have you ever had a conversation
with like a radical feminist about this kind of thinking? No,
they won't talk to me. They all blocked me.
They block you Yale and he all black, you know the whole,
the whole black left feminist.
The reason why they blocked me is cause they can't beat me. Right.
When we have conversations,
I'm so objective that it's too dangerous for them to engage with me. How so?
Cause I'll be like, it's sexist. Yes. And so let's,
let's continue the conversation and then that's where they don't want to go,
cause then they're going to have to provide reinforcement and evidence and
they're dealing with an educated man and I'm going to come with my evidence and
facts so you don't have a problem being sexist.
That's what the problem is because if someone calls you sexist and you go, yeah,
yeah, I'm sexist. Yeah, it is what it is. It's like a,
somebody called me a racist or whatever. I don't care what your opinion is.
I don't care about these isms that you create. I understand nature.
I understand myself. That's an interesting thing that I see today.
This I find really strange is that people that are denying evolutionary biology,
I mean there's yeah, decades of research being done,
why people behave the way they behave, what women are attracted to,
what men are attracted to and what the spectrum is, and then they say,
scientists racist. Yeah. That's what it's weird.
Science is sexist to fuck your science.
It's fucking fascinating to me when people don't want to look at it because it
doesn't support their ideology. They want to deny all this research,
deny all these really objective geniuses that have been studying all this stuff.
And the best minds in the field have come to these conclusions based on just
insurmountable amounts of data. Not Interested. Duh. So fine.
I'll put Sharky I have a shirt that says I am the patriarchy.
You know, like no matter what you throw at me, I'm just going to embrace it.
I'm going to show, yeah, Israel, there is a patriarchy.
There's also a matriarchy.
You need to handle your matriarchy and stop worrying about the patriarchy.
Cause if you handled your matriarchy to patriarchy wouldn't be your problem.
Your problem is you don't have to be a woman.
What do you think is a good piece of advice for women on how to be a woman?
A good piece of violence. Like woman Hotep hotep teaches women.
Hotep teaches women what's good, emotional control. Emotional control.
And uh, so, so the number one problem I see with women is a,
um, damn slot here. Right? Um, all right, let's go here. Okay.
Women let their friends, they tell their friends they business. Yes.
Stopped. Stop telling your friends your, but it stopped you.
Like when I have problems with it,
you know my girl or you know in the past when I have problems with women,
I didn't run back Yogis with Moodle. Oh man, we don't do that.
If my friends do that, they better be laughing. Right?
If my friend goes to it, he's not going to believe what this shit said to me.
If they give you a hard time about it,
but if they go to the new MOOC wants me to quit my job, like, hey
don't do that to me, man. Put that shit on me. Yeah. You know, I'm so, so,
so I think women also, you have to understand that they're,
they're giving this information to a friend who is also single.
When a woman gets in a relationship, she loses her friend, right?
Cause now you have less time to spend with your bestie. So the best,
he's jealous of the relationship.
So whenever you go back and tell her she's never going to give you sound advice.
True. She's always going to take your side.
So you have to judge your friends and say, well,
if I'm giving this information to my friend and see an objective friend or she,
a subject of French is going to feed my ego and then you can't analyze that on
your own, then you'll never have peace in your relationship.
Cause the worst thing to do is here's the problem in relationships built on
trust.
So if a man and a woman come together and you tell all my business to your
friend, where's the trust? Where's our privacy? We have none, right?
We have none. We don't have a relationship.
You have a relationship with your friend. So go be with your friend.
I don't got time to be, you know, I, something happens in my personal life.
I'm going to go tell this strange girl what happened in my personal life.
Something I told you that was private to relate it to something else that could
be happening in our relationship. You know what I mean? It's a thing.
We have different instincts. Women have the instinct to gossip. They love it.
It comes from that hunter gatherer culture where back in the day that's what
would happen.
The men would go out and try to hunt the food and the women would stay home and
they would talk shit. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Again, discipline yourself. Women.
Yeah. Stuff ladies. Another thing, get a hobby healthy one.
Women don't have hobbies. Their hobbies are all in consumer consumerism.
Don't have hobbies. Oh, all of them. All not, not all.
Oh I know women with hobbies, all of them.
But you know, in my book I say, you know, say all because it gets to people.
Go get some upset. Yeah. It gets people going. Cause they always go, well, no,
it's so dumb. It's like I know it's some Jamar around, you know what I'm saying?
But I say, oh just to get people going. But majority women don't have hobbies,
you know, do something that is uh, cause they're inundated with advertising.
You know, their hobbies become consumerism and Oh, you know,
retail therapy or you know, I do makeup for fun. No,
you don't do makeup for fun. That's not what you do. That's not a hobby.
Makeup's not a hobby. I'm sorry ladies. A hobby is something that develops your,
your individual person, something that makes you better.
Some kind of a discipline as some kind of form. Right.
Some way to express yourself. Some physical thing that you do. Yeah.
Like so like one of my hobbies is chess, right? That helps me focus when I,
when I see that my attention span is getting short,
cause I spent too much time on social media.
I go to chess and I'll spend time on chess to bring that back to reality.
You play physical chest. Would you play online? Uh, online? Yeah,
I can do OTB but you know, I do most OTB over the board.
Oh, what's that means? Physical, that's what you call it. Yeah. It's called OTB.
You do speed chess. We hit the timer. Do you do regular chess? Well, online,
I do speeches. I do a five minute games.
That's impressive. Yeah. Yeah. It's, it's, it's a whole nother woman.
Scared of chess. I've always been scared of other,
I have an obsession with games, real problems. And chess is a, it's one of them.
I've, I've played it a little bit, but I'm like, fuck,
this could take over my life.
It would. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, I'm a, if I'm not careful,
I'll be sleeping and, and playing chess. Oh yeah. You know,
like sometimes I'll be chilling,
like we'll be having a conversation and I'll space out and be doing chest
problems in my head. Uh, so that happens sometimes, you know, a lot,
especially on days that I play a lot of chess. I remember
it's terms really getting into Chesney was taking private lessons he was talking
about all the time. And I think he found the same thing. Do you remember that?
I think he found the same thing. I think he just got too obsessed with it.
He's like, I can't fucking do this anymore.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, one of my life goals is to be a chess master one day. Yeah.
Yeah. You know? And when you say chess master,
what do you have to do to be a master? Okay.
So you have national master and then you have a international master and then
you have a game master or the GM, I forget what it's called.
A national master. You have to participate in,
I believe one of the tournament's, one of the, uh, I forget the federation. Um,
but you have to enter one of these tournaments and you have to place a certain,
uh, you know, I think it's maybe top two or top three at a certain tournament.
Don't quote me on this stuff, but you have to go through the tournament.
And I think in order to become international,
you have to first become national master and then national match.
You can go be international, if I'm not mistaken. And then, you know, GM,
do you ever see the video of Eddie Fisher or Bobby Fischer?
When Bobby Fischer was walking down this row of chess games,
he was playing like 10 different games simultaneously.
Yeah. Um, uh, the, the, the, the champ now, uh, Carlson,
uh, does something similar, uh, where Carlson will, uh, play, you know,
several people
full or he'll play without a board. That always interested me.
I've seen people do that. Yeah. This dude I knew who went to prison,
was playing with his pool holiday's play out in white plains executive
billiards. And this kid was a chess master. He's like a 16 year old,
I don't know, master music, chess genius, 16 year old kid. Um,
and he was playing with this dude who was like in his forties who had been in
prison. He learned how to play chess with no board in prison.
So they was just sitting across from each other talking,
saying the moves and then they would both like recognize where the pieces were
on the board. Yeah. Really interesting.
Yeah. I mean that,
that level of visualization is where humanity has to take itself.
You know?
That's why I say chess is great because it allows you to visualize and in order
to manifest your desires in this world,
you have to be able to visualize what you want. The more you can focus,
the more you can visualize, the better your mind is, I believe,
because our is based upon visualization. You see what I'm saying? Yeah.
Um, uh, women need to get back to that, to visualizing goals.
I think women are, are very spiritual. So, uh,
in Africa, this, this, uh, Oh man, I'm slipping on my studies. I studied,
it's a long time ago, but, uh,
the man is a holding the child and the woman is pointing up to the sky,
right? And it's like the man is like that earthly thing.
Like we handle things in a physical and the woman's sorta like that into
intuitive being.
Women have to get back to being that intuitive being, because if you notice,
our women always seem to warn us about stuff, right? Like, Oh, don't do this.
I'm like, Damn, I should've listened to at that time. Yeah.
You know what I'm saying? They have to get back to their spiritual nature.
And I think a lot of them get away from that and that a ground them to when they
won't need so much emotional support from friends and family because they're
back in their spiritual nature. Well, how does a woman do that?
You start with meditating, you know, meditating, um, being happy,
which is being alone with yourself.
A lot of people can be alone with themselves. Yeah. You know,
they always need like some sort of device or
interesting that it's attractive when people are capable of being alone. Yeah.
I remember these two girls were talking about some God that one of them was
dating and she goes, yeah, he's really into his career, which is a huge turn on.
I was like, oh, that's interesting. Yeah. He just needs time. He's disciplined.
He works all the time. He's always working on his career,
which was a huge turn on and I was like, well, you total cluckers.
Well, women have to get back
to that too. Like you, I learn how to pick a good man.
Sometimes y'all are picking crap men based upon the money or things that they
have. You're getting related to, you finalize $100,000 in debt.
Ah, Douche, right? Yeah. He's got these things.
I think women have to get better at seeing potential in men,
but don't they have to be tricked a few times before they can see the problems.
Problem. Variance. Yeah. That's a fucking dirty thing for a girl.
Let some loser fuck you and go. God Damn it. Yeah. Yeah. I had them,
I thought I had a winner. Yeah. I mean, I, I've been a victim of debt. I will,
not in the victim, but you know, I've done that to women myself. Sorry ladies.
You know, we're all that good day. Yeah. Yeah. I had done some wrong stuff.
Well, we'd become a different person as time goes on. Yeah. You grow from it.
Part of evolution of human. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think a society's expectations on women are, um,
it's very difficult for a man to understand it. You know,
we see it from the outside, but to feel it as a woman,
it's gotta be very different. I mean,
there's a lot of women out there that are looking for a man,
like a successful man.
They're looking for a successful man and they want to touch themselves.
And that's like, that's the goal. Yeah, there's not, that's not a goal of men.
So it's, it's very difficult for us to understand that our goal for PR,
you know, obviously we're generalizing, right?
But our goal is to be successful ourselves,
right? Well, you can't,
you can't know what man you want unless you know who you are.
And a lot of people are getting relationships without being in relationship with
themselves first. So when, um, you know,
in order to
okay,
have a sound relationship, you have to know your socioeconomic stance.
Okay.
Is Sad when you get into a relationship with a conservative and you're liberal.
And He,
I start arguing about Donald Trump in a relationship breaks because he's on one
side. These are the conversations that you need to have upfront.
And if you don't know where you are politically and socioeconomically,
for example, they say a lot of relationships break up because of money, right?
I, you got one person's a bad spender. The other one's thrifty, right?
These are the conversations you need to have first.
How do you manage your money? No. Are you good with your money? You know,
and if you guys don't agree with how you want to pull your resource and how you
want to pull your money and what you want to do with it in a future, you know,
some people,
you know you might get in a relationship with a girl and she's like,
I want to push, you know, I want to Land Rover and I'm like,
I want a business. I want a VC. You know what I mean?
So you have two people that are go in separate directions.
One going as consumer route one's going into pending, you know, producer route.
So you have to first see, are you consumer? Maybe you need to be a con.
What a consumer are you a producer? You don't need to be what to consume,
what you need to find some minus producer. So if you,
if you agree on socioeconomics, you'll have a better relationship with people,
but you have to know what you want out of life first and then find people
connected based upon that, not the physical looks and all that other stuff.
Yeah.
I think sometimes people think they want something because it's very difficult
to attain. They see these things and they go, oh, that's the, that's the prize.
Yeah. Well, you know, the thing is he stuff aren't hard to obtain. Like,
you know, getting a Porsche isn't hard. Right? It's hard for a lot of people.
Depends on how much money, what you do, what kind of job you're trapped in.
Heart is relative. Right. You know, like, like I tell my kids, heart is,
uh, basically undiscovered. That's all it is. Right? So for example,
when you first do Algebra, it's hard, right? But that's just because it's new.
So hard equals new. MMM. That's what hard means.
It's new because once you do Algebra three, four, five,
10 times is not new anymore. And therefore it's not hard.
So once you break past the, the newness of a thing,
it's no longer hard. Like building a business. It's not new to me.
Therefore it's not hard. It's very easy for me to build a business.
Yeah. Because I've done it so many times in my life is what I'm saying.
[inaudible]
is cash flowing four x what it was doing when I first joined the company.
And all I do is make a few tweaks,
but that's only because I'm not new to the tech startup space.
I've been working with over 20 startups, over 20 startups in the, in, in,
in a matter of two, three years as a, so this stuff, when people say, oh,
it's hard, it's like, no, no, not hard.
[inaudible] it's new and you're an idiot and you don't know what you're doing.
It's not hard to achieve anything in his life. My, uh, you know,
I used to work for 50 same, right? And, uh, uh, I, uh,
when I lived in New Brunswick, right by Rutgers, I wasn't really a 50 cent fan.
I enjoyed his music, but I wasn't a fan to buy a poster.
I bought this poster was him and g unit and he had this big stash of money and I
was like, Yo, this just, this poster motivates me.
You fast forward 10 years and some other things I did to get close to 50 and I
actually work with 50. That was technically hard, right?
It's not easy to get nick to 50 but when I did it, it happened like that.
Then I started working with Carmelo Anthony.
So you're saying once it actually happened,
it turned out it wasn't actually hard. No. Harder to some people, no,
they're just not disciplined.
The hard hard is dealing with yourself.
That's what's hard. Can you defeat your own mind?
So when I wake up every morning, the only thing I got to defeat is doubt.
It's the only thing I have to defeat. Once I defeat doubt,
I live in a a limitless world. Infinite possibilities.
I can literally do anything you sold. So people told me, Oh,
in order to be in tech, you know you need $1 million and and this, that,
and the third dude, I got equity in three tech companies,
three tech companies, and I'm not rich. I didn't, you know,
put up millions to get into these companies.
I'm part of these companies because I built me and it wasn't hard.
It really wasn't hard to get into these companies.
I just had something to offer and they saw value in me.
I want to be the next Elon Musk. I want to be the next Bill Gates.
I want to be the guy that Zuckerberg hates. You see what I'm saying?
I want to be the guy that that builds the new silicon valley on the east coast.
You know that like that's, those are my aspirations.
So when people tell me what you can and cannot do and it is hard, I'm like,
dude, I'm selling bitcoin.
How many black dudes do you know sell bitcoin?
None. I don't know anybody who sells bitcoin. Exactly.
And people are telling me, this is hard. It's not hard. You, you,
you get what you want. And I didn't get into bitcoin out of dumb luck.
I manifested that. I said I wanted to sell bitcoin. How can I manifest it?
Then I let it go and the universe brought me an opportunity and then it happened
when I said, when I first said I want to be a VC.
First thing I want to do is start building a portfolio.
I didn't look for companies. They found me. It just,
I just had to ask the universe and it presented opportunities.
And not just had to because what do you mean by how to ask the universe?
I had to put the intention out there.
So do you think that literally by thinking about things you can make them
happen.
You can make the opportunity present itself and then you have to be ready to
take advantage. So let's, we've got to walk through the story to 50 cent thing,
right? So I get invited to his bus launch, right? For the company.
Now I'm sitting on the bus,
they move me to the back because of security reasons.
So I'm going to back at a bus. When a bus started moving in, my head,
fear kicks in and doubt kicks in and I'm telling myself I should just hop,
we with the bus stop. And I said, I should just hop up and just start screaming.
I'm on a bus or 50 cents and I'm like, Nah, I don't do ag Dane.
And why did you wire? You've got to sit here and that's not right.
And you know all these things society says is right. So I stand up and I go,
Yo want a bus with 50 cent. Right. And in the whole crowd rushes the bus.
After the crowd finishes, they take one of the a energy drink shirts.
They throw it on me, throw the hat on me. They bring me to the front of the bus.
Now I'm sitting next to 50 cent. Fast forward two years later,
I'm in a 50 st company,
but it's because I started off with defeat and doubt,
but also listening to my intuition. My intuition said to hop up and do that.
Right. But the opportunity was presented to me. I didn't,
I didn't create the opportunity. They DM me and said, Yo, we want you to come.
I didn't ask. They invited me,
but it's because I kept putting that 50 cent energy out there. Hmm.
He assumes I kept putting that out there. Like, y'all won't mess with 50 cent.
I won't miss it for 10 years.
I've been putting information that energy out there, 50 of you listening, Johan,
let me, I want to work with you again.
Um, but I really, I just really love 15 his attitude.
He's just really a fun dude.
Do you know what a funny thing about father's Day is?
He's roundabout father's Day, Father's day and mother's Day. Very funny.
You know the universe. Anything you ask for it,
we'll present the opportunity. The only thing is, are you woken up to see it?
Can you identify when it hits and, and, and can you defeat the fear to,
to, to, to,
and do you have all the other bases in your life covered where you have the
bandwidth to tackle some correct. Difficult, correct. Correct.
But usually the unit
verse only presents you opportunities you can handle. They don't yet.
Usually it doesn't. Cause if you couldn't handle it,
you wouldn't be able to recognize it. Do you say this like, like
the universe presents this to you. This is like a spiritual concept.
Is this like, are you manifesting reality with your thoughts and intentions?
Do you really believe that? All of that. Why do you believe that?
Because I lived it. I experienced it,
but you lived it and you're successful at it. See that's my,
my perspective on that is always you hear about things like the secret in the
law of attraction. You hear that from people that are successful. They say,
well I willed it into existence. Yeah,
but what about the people that tried to will it into existence and nothing ever
worked out right. Or at [inaudible] right. Or at Laboy Latin for work and pray.
A lot of people go into the secret and they just praying but they ain't working
right. That's important. You know? So I do see what you're saying.
I don't look at it in the same way, but I look at it in a similar way.
I think there is something to intention.
There's something and there's also to having
that kind of faith to believe in intention. Whereas I think a lot of people do,
they're reluctant to give into that because it seems too woo woo and it seems
like some crystals and fucking astrology and horse shit. You know what I mean?
Cause there's a lot of that out there. A lot of them,
the new age has ruined the law of attraction. You know what I mean? It's like,
oh, just speaking into the system and happened. Now that's not true.
You have to first educate yourself. So when we talk about Hotep, right?
When you talk about Hotep, you got to bring up the 5% nation.
You've got to bring up supreme mathematics, zero cipher one, knowledge, two,
wisdom, three understanding. But it first starts it, the number one, right?
Number one is knowledge. So the problem is people that try to manifest,
but he ain't got no knowledge of anything, right?
So how do you manifest something with no knowledge? You got to educate yourself.
You've got to first start educating yourself on disability yourself so that you
can educate yourself as well,
right? And also knowledge is the springboard for imagination,
right? So if there's a complicated calculus problem,
what you don't know what calculus is,
how can intuition feeds you a insight or inspiration to solve a cargos problem?
You first have to have the knowledge of Calculus. Then when you get it,
you get all this influx of inspiration, like onstart talks about, you know,
he sits down, he kind of Meditates, and then the inspiration comes.
But the inspiration can only talk to you based upon your understanding
because he was saying yes.
So the problem is people out here not educating themselves. You know, I,
I, I,
my day begins and ends with educating myself and begins ends and during the day
I'm just reading books,
hopping between books and reading and listening to lectures and people think I'm
deep and I'm like, I don't know. I don't know, whatever, whatever. One,
I'm intelligent,
but really my secret is consuming as much information as possible.
That's my secret. And in from that I'm able to say, oh well, you know, Duh,
you know, studying history, you know, you can, you can do a lot of things,
but if you're not educating yourself or doing,
you got to do something like just start, you know what I mean?
When you say you're going to write a new book,
you're in the middle of writing a book.
Are you putting this kind of stuff in your book? All right,
so the next guidelines like that, I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but guidelines like that is the thing that's very critical.
When someone sees someone who's successful and see someone and they see someone
who's disciplined and focused like, okay, what are you,
what are your guidelines? How do you do this? And how,
like the way you're laying it out, like right now. So, so this book here, right?
This Twitter marketing,
yeah, this book is the how, how do you do it, right?
Like how do you physically build a brand from start using Twitter as a platform?
That is, a book can actually be used for any platform.
I just use Twitter as the example, right?
But this is the how that people won't tell you about. Well,
markers won't tell you about this is the how, right?
It's all the Caesar's in here. Now the next book I have is with the editor.
It's done. It's written. That's for men.
And how to have peaceful relationships with women. Right?
Cause as we see it as a gender worn in America. So we need to create peace.
And what I say is default isn't on the women. The fold is on the men, right?
So that book was, uh, uh, the cover was designed by rural Tomasi.
The rational male author.
Then we have the book of Hotep was what you're talking about,
which is already written. I wrote it two, three years ago. And it's that, that,
uh,
structure for your life so you can manifest these things, you know,
so you can use spirit in your work to manifest. He stinks.
If you're a Christian, there's secrets in the Bible that show you how to,
you know, manifest things. So you have to,
you, you can't ignore your spiritual self. If you ever watched Dr Strange,
she pushes him out and his astral body comes down.
So the human being is his dual nature. We have our physical Biden,
we have our astral body. Have you never connect with, to astral body,
you only use half of your potential. What's your Astrobotic a it's,
it's basically a,
any theory you will version of
your, uh, physical body,
but it's not bound by time and space. So what do you mean by that though?
What does that mean? What do you mean? What does that mean?
The real version of your spiritual body? Like it's not physical.
You can't touch it. Okay. Right. You can't like interact with it, right?
But it can travel through space and time, right?
All we talk about our higher selves,
all we can to make things more understandable.
Cause all this stuff is based upon a subconscious mind, right?
So you use the subconscious mind to program.
I mean you use your conscious mind to program your subconscious mind.
The subconscious mind communicates it to your higher mind than a higher mind.
That's where the magic stuff happens, is out of your control.
Now the higher mind or spirit or God or Jesus, whatever you want to believe in,
that's when they start working on this stuff. But it has to be a part of you.
And then life starts reflecting what's in your subconscious mind.
But did the Astrobotic thing, I is kind of like a,
something that we use to either communicate with people in long distance,
traveled through time to see things that have happened and foreign lanes at
different times. Uh, get inspiration.
So when we look at thinking grow rich, right?
The book thinking grow rich was to tell you to do.
It tells you create a council of,
I think he says dead people or something like that. Right?
He said create a council of debt, people your counsel. Right?
So if I did mine and probably be like Malcolm x to pop Nipsey Hussle,
you know like oh a bunch of people, right?
And you have this congregation meeting of minds,
you can't do that with your physical body.
So who's going to be present at this meeting?
The astral body has to be president as mean.
So that's an example of how we've seen that science taught in thinking grow
rich. Right? So we can't stay. This stuff is like,
aren't you saying when you're talking about like a council of dead people,
you're saying like your imagination, your,
you're looking at this council of dead people. Like what would Tupac do?
Like Damn Shit. What, how would I draw inspiration from Ali? How would I,
how would I take the, the, the, the knowledge of, you know,
fill in the blank. Whoever's dead. Yeah. Brilliant. Yeah.
So there is that aspect, right? Where it's your imagination, right?
What would Jesus do? Right? Well that is, that's the thing, right? So,
but what we have to understand is there's going to be a sliver of inspirational
insight. So let's say 90% of your meeting with these people are pure physical,
your mind imagining these things, then there's that one sliver,
that one 10% that slides through that gives you that piece of inspiration that
you never would have thought about. It's like an idea that, you know,
sometimes you're telling me like, oh, oh yeah, you know,
that idea that just pops in your head. That is what happens.
Now once you get more advanced,
you can get more of that influx of inspiration from, you know,
Spirit or whatever you want to call it, get more advanced,
meaning practice this all the time. Yeah. Yeah. Practicing,
um, you know,
using your astral body to project out and being in another space, uh,
happy Gilmore cause of this happy space. You remember that movie? Yeah.
All right. So what did he do in order to manifest his dreams?
He went to his happy place to detach himself from his physical problems.
Hmm. I'm saying okay. And then he came back and he put, and it went to dirt,
dirt, dirt, dirt, dirt. There was like, he did the impossible.
So it's like they try and let you know.
So if you were to construct this and put this down in the guidelines,
you,
you're basically streamlining the process of how to be as successful and uh,
how to, how to just, yeah. Make your dream come true.
Make, make your reality how to be a person who's got their shit together.
Yeah. I, you know, the main thing is problem when people,
especially young people, is they don't know what they want to do.
They didn't know that passion or purpose. And again,
that just comes back to knowledge. Are you studying?
Take your interest and study it. When you get bored with it, drop it,
move on to the next thing. But you know,
like over the years I've collected a lot of skills,
all of them being used. Now, you know, like I'm not a Photoshop guy,
but I know how to use Photoshop.
But that happened because at one point I was running a blog.
I had to know how to edit something or do something, you know what I mean?
So just because it's not a skill you want.
Like at one point I had photography business when my space was popping out of
photography business. Now I don't do photography anymore,
but I understand it. So when I'm some place, I can still use these skills,
whether it's for a product or something or event,
I can still use these skills to my advantage. You know what I mean?
So even if you don't like that skill at that time,
it might come into play later. Right.
But the bottom line is you have to start with your knowledge and then,
and then allow the spirit or intuition to us to feed it
right loud to feed it. Like I don't use my logical mind.
Like my logical mind is, is only for after inspiration.
Right? You get that.
Yeah.
So you get inspired and then you use your logical mind to figure out how to make
this work.
Right. And that's where we have to be. Let the,
let the logical mind just carry out the menial tasks.
Let the higher man into wish and lead the way.
Now,
do you think of these things as being like separate entities or is this all all
part of you? That's all one. So you think when you think of your,
your higher mind, how do you visualize this? Do you do,
do you visualize this as something that you don't necessarily have control of
but you can tap into?
Yeah, I guess you could look at it like that. Like, you know,
I'm not the Dalai Lama on this topic. You know what I mean?
But you know I A to for one exercise,
what I might do is I love, I put light around my head.
I'll visualize a sphere of light around my head.
And you see this in religious texts. In Art,
you always see Jesus Christ or saints,
they always have this glow around their head. They call it a halo, right?
But really the halo is like your aura, right?
But also the second aspect is that when I want to use my brain in an events way,
I can start the firing of neutrons or whatever the technical term is by
visualizing something. Even if I want to visualize, you know,
thunderstorms in my head, you know, that'll get the brain working, you know?
But usually like light, if I want to do distant healing, right?
Let's say you tell me you sick, right? I probably shouldn't be saying this, but,
um, if I want to do this in healing, I would envelop you in light.
I would sit at home rest, make sure you sleep.
Then I would picture light around your work.
Do you think that you can do that?
Do you think you can actually heal people from a distance?
No. You're not healing anything.
What you're doing is you're giving the intention to God that you want this
person to be healed in God or the universe is healing.
We can't heal a damn thing.
Right? But you really think that by thinking about something,
you can put that intention now, the little change the result.
Yes. Really. What makes you think that? Uh,
well they have these scientific tests. Ah, I haven't studied this in a while,
but there's a test where they fire like these electrons or something like that
and the electrons are supposed to be like on a predictable path.
And then when they introduce people to the experiment,
the intensity, you don't take the wave spirit. You know,
the problem with that is that's misinterpreted. Okay. The, the,
the real change is in observing it. Yes.
But the change is in observing it because you're measuring it.
So by measuring it, you changing the pattern.
Like if you talked to a real physicist about it,
they'll say they've added all this woo woo to this. That's unnecessary.
Because really what it is is just the tools,
the instrument to use them to measure it or change their results.
Yeah. Yeah. I could definitely see that.
The thing is that physics has to marry spirituality and spirituality has to,
Matt has to marry a physics. If you don't have that connection between the two,
we don't got the whole picture.
MMM. Spirituality is a weird word. What does that mean?
It's a, a very taboo word is a very abused word.
It's abused for sure. It's, I'm not religious, but I'm spiritual.
I'm like that kind of shit. Yeah. That's where it gets weird.
Yeah. I don't like that at all. You know, when I speak about spirituality,
I'm speaking about something that really can't be put into words.
It's unfathomable. You know,
our language isn't designed to talk about this stuff. You know,
when we look at all well and new speak,
there's certain words that don't exist for this stuff.
You'd have to use a, an ancient language and even ancient language,
you try to translate it to English. It's like, we don't have a word for this.
You ever had
like ancient Hebrew when they try to translate things ancient Hebrew,
all the numbers were actually all the letters rather actually numbers as well,
correct? Correct. Yeah. Um,
do you know when you talk about Halos that the original halo was a mushroom cap?
Yeah, a mushroom cap. Oh, you're talking about, okay.
I got to the original halo [inaudible] was, well,
there's a book called the sacred mushroom in the cross.
It's by John Marco Allegro,
and he was a biblical scholar that was one of the guys that was assigned to
decipher the Dead Sea Scrolls, which is the oldest version of the Bible,
the only one I think that they've ever found. It's written in Aramaic,
and it was found in Qumran and these clay clay tap these clay jars and it's
there. It's all made unwritten on animal skins to decipher it.
They actually had to run DNA tests on the animal skins to figure out which skins
belonged to which animals.
So they could put all this stuff together to figure out like, oh, this,
all these pieces were a part of this one scroll. Yeah. Well this guy,
John Marco Allegro,
studied it for 14 years and it was his conclusion after he was done that the
entire Christian religion was a giant misunderstanding.
And what it was originally about was the consumption of psychedelic mushrooms
and fertility rituals.
And they started doing all of these like these different scholars who studied
ancient art and ancient religious art. They started finding these,
this mushroom iconography and all this ancient artwork.
And one of the things they notice is that the bottom of a mushroom you could
take like particularly the Amazon and miscarry and mushroom,
which is the one that they connect to, um, to, uh,
the Christian religion.
Look at the bottom of it and see what it looks like with all those lines.
Now look at that. That was the original halo.
If you see that picture about with Jesus, with the halo around his head,
the halo was essentially the bottom of a mushroom cap.
And the idea they believe was that these people were the ones that were
consuming the psychedelic mushrooms. So they had this great wisdom and this,
this connection to God.
That's what they thought Mana was that as they thought these psychedelic
mushrooms where the flesh of God, I liked it. Yeah.
And so that when you have these ancient religions that were possibly based on
the consumptions of the psychedelic mushrooms,
all that stuff has kind of been lost in the translation over years and years and
years. And then even the visualization of the Halos change. Yeah.
And there's also some really crazy ones of, um, naked people dancing.
And ecstasy surrounded by this translucent mushroom image.
So the idea that they were in these mushroom induced euphoric states and that
they were dancing around these, all these religious depictions. Yeah.
Very interesting. Because if you think about ancient religions, right? No,
no science. They had no idea what shaped the world was.
They didn't know anything. But they did know,
if you found these mushrooms and you took them, you trip your fucking balls off,
right. You would have this incredible experience and they thought that was God,
you know, that there was, that was their connection to God. You know?
So there's, that's interesting. Yeah,
it's a great book in the Catholic Church actually bought it out and they, uh,
they, they got rid of it and then you could only buy used copies of it,
but then it was republished recently over the last few years.
Someone got the rights to it. [inaudible] yeah. That's interesting.
Intense stuff. Yeah. I liked that conversation. Yeah, that's sexy.
You know, anything that goes away from the norm I think is real sexy.
So needs to and need to be taught. It needs to be talked about. You know,
you get a sexy woman that accused Trump rape.
I said that she was talking about rape being sexy. Yes.
Anderson Cooper's like we'll be right back. Cut to commercial. What?
Yeah, she's a loony bin. Well, she seems like she might be medicated. Yeah,
you can definitely tell there's something off there. Yeah, maybe.
Maybe she's super nervous being on television too. That's also, oh no.
It's hard to figure out how people are when you see them on television because
I like to consider myself a good judge of character. She's off her rocker.
She seems off her rocker. I don't know him personally. I mean,
some people really do have panic attacks when the camera's on that white light
during the CNN studios and then
when it just comes out weird and then they like,
what the fuck was wrong with me? Right, right. Yeah. Yeah. I could see that.
I don't think in her case, I think she's just really like,
do things. Just try to sell a book. Just trying to sell something.
She definitely wants some attention, you know? But um, Teflon, Donnie,
she can't do nothing. Teflon on thought.
It's crazy how he's been able to shake everything off everything.
If you stay in 10 toes down, he came. I ain't do nothing to you.
That's why I keep saying like,
don't worry about these tech companies staying 10 toes down, stand 10 toes down.
What does that mean? Stand on your, you know, stand on your foot, man.
Like you know, like stand your ground, you know,
is it don't waiver just because somebody says something. You know,
I get criticized a lot online in my responses. I said, what? I said,
you know, I'll,
I'll infuriate the left and I infuriate the right and the right to feel like,
well last week you were approached Trump and now you're saying something that's
different. It's like, and well,
you got the most shit I think for that Starbucks video.
The Starbucks video was hilarious when you walked into Starbucks and he said,
Oh, who you out? You guys are racist. I'm here to get my free Starbucks.
And that lady was like, okay, Amanda, shout out to Amanda.
She's like, yeah, I heard that. Hold on, I'll get you a coffee. It's like,
I didn't know you could just give away coffee. You work at Starbucks.
But I guess she just did. I manifested that. Where was that?
That was a New Jersey Woodbury Commons mall thing. That's hilarious.
Yeah. But you know,
like I manifested it and you can go look at the tweet two weeks before said,
I said, uh, if you want to be on mainstream media, pretend to be liberal.
Then I also said, I said to my followers, I said, can y'all get me on Fox News?
The next week I pulled this stunt and then got on Fox News.
Now when they had you on Fox News, what was the premise?
What were they going to talk? What'd they say? Hey, I just want the story.
They just want some, hey,
just wanted some shit that I probably wanted a little bit, a potential outrage.
Like this guy asking for coffee. Reparations. Yeah.
You got a black guy who's asking for reparations. They kind of liked that.
Especially when it's spoofing the left. So yeah, they, you know, they,
they kind of wanted to weaponize me. Yeah. Um, so yeah, there's a lot of that.
I thought it was funny. I thought was hilarious.
You were very friendly about it, you know,
it wasn't like you were being angry or anything.
Did you have your son with you or someone to yeah, my boys.
The whole family was at me. That's funny man. Yeah. Yeah.
My son didn't and he was like,
I told him I go here and get free coffee saying yeah, right.
[inaudible] I was like, your dad's really about to pull this off bro.
You had a debate recently about reparations with uh, CJ peers. Yes.
That young guy who's, um, very, he's an interesting guy.
Very, very intelligent and articulate fellow.
Isn't he like 19 years old or something like that? 16 yeah.
Is He really only 16? 18. Yeah. Really? Yeah, that's what they say.
At least I thought he was older than that.
He writes for Colette and he's really only 16. Yeah.
CJ Pearson. Is that what it is? Funny how old you is? That seems crazy.
It got drunk. Pays 16. Wow. It's got fucking smart as shit. No,
he's not, but now it's not. Why do you think he's not smart? He's not smart.
Smart people create things stupid place.
Fucking 16 you don't think he's got an exceptional vocabulary and ability to
express himself at 16 and what does that mean? Well,
it means you've got something going on. I don't need shit. It doesn't mean shit.
That's an exception of you. Speed is absolute sometimes.
What is vocabulary mean you? Some words.
Well you have use of them at the access. Instantaneous access.
That means they're in your mind all the time,
which means you've done a lot of reading,
which means you've done a lot of studying,
which means you have a command of the English language,
which was the only thing that we have. If you speak English,
that you can use to express your intent. Right?
And An Orwell talks about these political types who sound very educated.
He says it, they sound very educated on it. Right?
And then when you break down what they actually said, it's still very vague.
It's all very nonspecific. There's actually no solutions. You know?
All they do is talk about problems. What is your platform? CJ Pearson.
Candace hones. What is your platform? Is your platform? I Hate Democrats.
Is your platform.
I want something for the people because it seems like when you watch these
people, they're all saying the same thing for clicks.
Like I told you my homeboy, he makes all that money on Facebook.
He's doing the Candice SolarWinds and CJ Pearson thing for money.
Are they the same? They're not. They don't have the same ideology.
CJ Pearson's and Candice owns. They're cut from the same cloth. You think so?
They're the same person. He's just younger version.
I heard him speak on the Sam Harris show. I believe it was him. Right?
Was it him? CJ Sees Google that CJ Pearson on Sam p.
I'm pretty sure it's the same cat [inaudible] and I was very impressed.
Especially with some of his age. Yeah.
I mean he talks very wow and he was so hard to do and here in the United States
of America was not him after both the names and nothing. Okay.
Maybe it's a different dude. They have pre. That's why I thought he was older.
Catchphrases, preplanned, catch freezes. You're, you're learning.
You're just learning. Another language. And that's, that's what he's,
he's speaking that language. There's no digging him. That's, that's little bro,
you know, dig on him. I see what you're saying.
So you're saying that they have this sort of ideology that are subscribing to
this predetermined pattern of behavior.
They know what works and then they just follow it. Sorta like a top 40 DJ talks.
There you go. Right, right. You know, like what,
what has with new thought has he created? I don't know. He hasn't. He hasn't.
I just listened to that debate and, um,
it's a conversation that I think is a fascinating one,
the conversation of reparations because it can be no doubt that something
horrible happened to the black community and they're still suffering from it as
parents, especially in the deep south.
And you look at these places where the people who lived or the direct
descendants of slaves,
and then these are the same impoverished neighborhoods that no one's ever done
anything to try to fix. Right? So how do you fix it?
You first have to start with the subconscious mind and the black mind. Uh,
and the problem with the black mind is the fact that the black mind starts off
with a fetus mentality from the day you're born, you're taught, uh,
the white man's out to get you. So you start off with a boogeyman and then, um,
you're taught that you're a slave, right? Uh,
so when your subconscious mind believes that the beginnings of your race is a
slave, how do you aspire to be more than that?
So in order to correct the black community, you have to teach black
history or so called black history or what I would say African history and
chronological order. Before we were slaves, we were kings. So how do you,
how do you have a whole entire nation of 40 some odd million black people and
majority of them never heard a queen Angola who never heard of the Songhai
Empire, the Mali Empire, you know, none of this stuff, right? King, Masa, Masa.
How do you, how do you,
how do you raise a people's level of awareness about this stuff and how do you
elevate them to want to do things in life when they think they are slave?
That's the first thing that you have to do to help black people.
You have to teach them who they are.
That expression, before they were slaves, they were kings.
The problem with that as a king,
as a monarch and a mark is one person who controls giant groups of people.
You can have a bunch of kings.
There's not a lot of kings can have a nation of kings. Correct,
but that's very different from saying, you know that we had four kings,
right? Let's say there were just four, right? That's betted insane.
Harry Tubman, Frederick Douglas, and these free slaves, right?
You actually have to see at least one king. I see what you're saying.
At least say so.
See One advanced human being that also looks like you,
that came from the same part of the world where your ancestors came from,
so recognize that the trajectory that you and your family are on as a direct
result of being enslaved,
that someone was enslaved in the past and brought over here against their will.
That's why there's the negative mindset.
That's why there's a negative self image is because there's this great history
of oppression. Yeah. Yeah. You know, when you think you are slave,
you can't operate outside of that. And even if you don't think you're a slave,
you think you're inferior. You know, you don't know who ms pat is. No.
Hilarious comedian, one of the funniest human beings alive and she was here.
And one thing she was talking about was when she was younger that when she would
see white people, she wouldn't look them in the eye. She would get nervous.
She felt inferior being around them. She just wanted to get away.
She didn't feel like she belonged. Right,
right. And that's a product of not knowing who you are,
not knowing your own personal power. You know,
when you look at the second Punic war as a Carthage,
you had a Hannah bull went through the Alps, which is an, you know,
mission impossible. And he went all the way to the,
to the doors of Rome and Rome said, Yo,
we ain't coming outside to fight you bro. When he come in.
That's how strong the power for the army was. They said, we don't want to fight.
They knew if they came outside those gates, they would get their ass. Whoop.
So how do you,
how do you have a people that walk around not knowing that a Hannibal,
a barker is a welst,
a studied war general today. The Pentagon still studies him.
Right? So how do you, how you operate in,
in America as a black person and not know who Annabelle Bargo goes?
Well, it's difficult, I think for people that were born in American,
all their known ancestors from America to even relate.
Like I'm,
my family's mostly from Italy and Sicily and some of them from Ireland.
I don't relate at all. I visited Italy in the summer times.
I don't relate at all. Right? So then the other,
the other side is the fact that we would have natives,
we would not brought here on slave ships.
That's not economically sound, just doesn't make sense. Uh,
so when Christopher Columbus guy he had wanted to them,
has got to the Caribbean according to a primary source,
they basically said the first thing he did was take slaves.
He didn't bring slaves. He took slaves from the island. He captured people.
So when you have colonization,
you gotta remember United States was only built 13 colonies at first, right?
You think this whole land was empty? No, there were natives here. Right?
But today we're taught that natives as some other people.
No natives are the melanated African being that has come here since the, the,
the, the beginning of the Mali Empire. We're talking about, uh, 14,
13th century. We had already come here from Africa. Really?
Oh yeah. Yeah.
We had already come here to the United States or to this land mass.
This land mass we call the United States.
So the way to the ocean current works is it works, uh, from Africa,
leaves out of, uh, west Africa comes to South America and the Caribbean.
It's just how the currents go. You don't need no paddle boat and nothing,
it'll just occurrence. It's take you there and then you travel up.
But we had already been here. All you gotta do is look up the story of
Sarah Erector Sai Rector's, a wealthy, so-called native American. Um,
I think she was a Choctaw tribe or one of these tribes,
but she was wealthy and uh,
she wanted the VIP pass to go somewhere and um,
they had her classified as a free person.
Why don't we know about the wealthy so-called black people in America?
Why don't we know that there were black slave owners in America?
Why is that not taught? Why is it not? How many blacks labels man,
this did the natives here had slaves.
They were trading slaves with the so called white man. Well,
they definitely did that. Natives and slave people of other tribes, right?
So if those, if those people are us to so-called black man,
if those natives were us,
then we have to tell that history and say how we did have territories and we
did, you know, carry our commerce and we weren't slaves. We were slave owners.
What?
But the majority of African Americans that lived here were brought over here.
No, no, no. That's not economically sound.
What do you mean by it's not economically sound like they're worse, let's say.
All right. Let's say you wanted to have a, you wanted to sell marijuana, right?
Right. Would you, uh, import marijuana?
Would you grow here if it's already here? Well,
it depends on whether or not marijuana grew here. Well,
can you have marijuana here? You can. We're just talking about marijuana.
Like what does that something
that you can't grow here. So, so what I'm saying is people,
we're already here.
Does it make sense to go all the way to this other continent to bring people on
a boat when we know that half Istock is going to die?
You wouldn't do that.
So how many people do you think were brought over from Africa on slave ships?
Cause that definitely happened. I don't believe it.
What do you mean you don't believe it? I don't believe that story.
You don't believe that Africans were brought over on slave ships, correct?
I believe it may have happened. You know,
maybe people were brought over as slaves,
but I don't think that the black people in America came from Africa on slave
ships. I believe that people that were here were slowly conquered.
First they got to east coast and then they started spreading out west,
little by little Cochran. And when you conquer a tribe, what do you do?
You enslaved them. Their POW yes. Right? Okay. That's what you do.
So you, after you conquered his tribe, you, you, you make them slaves.
Now how do you conquer the natives here? So let's say you got,
this tribe is warn against this tribe. Well,
this tribe goes talk to the white man. My man says, Yo,
if you help me wipe out these people, then boom, you know,
I'll help you with whatever, whatever.
So they get together and they wipe out this other trop and I guess what the
white man now out numbers this trop say he wipes them out.
You just killed two birds with one stone. You just keep moving like that.
But I'm still confused.
There's a great history of slave ships being brought over from Africa with
Africans. That became slaves and worked in the south.
So that you think that's lies? History is his story, right?
What about my story is my story now valley,
but if you do 23 in me on someone from these parts of the country,
you'll find out 20 days. That's real. So, so there's 23 and me. So when I,
when I, when I take a a 23 and me test, right? Yes.
What's it going to tell me about Africa? That's a good question.
We should find out. We going to say, Oh,
you're from Kenya or you're from Angola, you're from this, this, right, right.
These things,
these borders were created by Europe in terms, yes.
In terms of like what parts of Africa and how it's distributed and what's a
country and what's not a country. Yeah. Afrikaners and Dutch. Yeah.
Okay. So you can't classify me based upon a European name.
I understand that. But they're saying geographically geographic location,
you can call it whatever name you want. Right.
They can tell you where your genetics originated.
Like I've got some weird shit in me. I got like 1% Asian.
I don't know why it's there. 1.6% African.
There's also the weird stuff that you find in your DNA then like your ancestors
and ancestors. Ancestors. So let's with someone, let's walk down that path,
right? So either way,
if you take black people here in America,
do they DNA sample and it point back to Africa. What does that say?
Says Black people in America are Africans. Now the argument where we brought
here or where we already here,
did we bring ourselves here or did the white man bring us here? You see,
when you say to white man brought us here,
which are doing is you're removing our ability to transport ourselves.
You're saying, oh, we didn't know anything about boats. That's a draw. Tommy.
You try to tell me that we didn't know that there was a landmass here.
The only the, the holy white man knew there was land to the west.
But when you look at the holy white man, he said, when we got here,
we met black people. Go look at the primary source is the guy.
We met black people. When you got to Caribbean, me, my black people.
You think the Caribbean is right next to America and a Warren in America.
That's interesting. Does it make any sense? Well,
are you going to setup sense that you do have people that have traveled,
whether it's Polynesians, have traveled to Hawaii or people,
I mean there's the old Mex, uh,
thousands and thousands of years ago in South America.
They have computerly clearly African faces. Yes.
I mean really letting the noses, the lips, I mean,
they look African and that was a South American culture that existed and we
don't know anything about them other than the fact that they have these gigantic
stones, sculptures that have African faces.
Like again, again, just go to have, you can pull up the ocean currents.
I've seen that. You've seen I met caucus. I've heard about him. Yeah.
Read his stuff. It's really fascinating because he's all about that.
He's all about the fact that the idea that human beings were probably living in
advanced civilizations far longer than 14,000 years ago.
They did travel all over the world and that you do find the remanence of these
ancient cultures that we have no explanation for throughout the Amazon,
you know, and throughout different parts of, of uh,
South America and Central America.
I mean, when you go and you look at rail European history,
you had the Magyars would believe that if they took a bath that was bad,
right? They didn't even want to change their clothes.
They thought that dirty was purity.
When we talk about the Moore's going into Spain and into Europe,
the stories in the history,
our history says that when we met the so called Caucasian,
he was sleeping in the barn with the animals and we told him, no,
you can't sleep in the barn was animals. We taught them etiquette.
We taught them running water. We brought that technology to Europe.
Now if we brought the technology to Europe that saved Europe from the black
plague, you mean to tell me that if we save the white race,
that we weren't already in America already when we brought the technology,
when Rome was depending on Africa for food.
I remember when a black print black plague hitting Rome.
The cause was uh, one of the, uh,
officials was still in the green. I was coming from Africa,
so there was famine hit Rome.
F Your source of
sustenance is from Africa. How will you superior?
You're not, you get your full from me. So if you get your full from me,
who's more likely to travel this globe may,
I'm the source of food and that's the first thing you need to survive on this
planet. So if your whole civilization is dependent me to plot,
to plot too dependent on me to supply fool, I made it to America first.
It's just that you won the war and you've got to tell the story.
Is that their only source of food? I mean it's a source of food that Rome had.
Right, but Rome is also very close to Africa. Let's talk about that.
What kinds of food did they have? Well, I don't know. It's a very rudimentary,
it was a very rudimentary civilization.
It wasn't all a what is cracked up to be.
When you go look at what the Greek said about Egypt. When you go into Egypt,
it's like Yo, it's like the New York City of that time. The ultimate,
if you really want to talk about African civilization being advanced Egypt as
the ultimate because Egypt to this day is still unexplained.
No one really understands how they built those things.
No one understands the how old the culture is.
That's another thing that Graham Hancock and doctor Robert Schoch from Boston
University who a geologist,
he's pointing to water erosion and the temple of the Sphinx.
That leads you to believe that that place might have been as old as 9,000 plus
BC. So it absolutely is. Yeah. If not older fellow Ramsey's.
There's also different styles of architecture, right?
There's some older styles of architecture they find deeper in the sand.
They think it might've been indicative of an earlier kingdom.
And then there's also the new bian structures of some of the faces,
particularly the Sphinx. Yeah. You know, the Sphinx,
they believe had a lion's face.
And then when they were conquered by the Nubians,
they changed the actual structure of the face of this face and turned it into a
a king's face.
What a way it was told to me was that it is upper and Lower Egypt.
So a Upper Egypt is actually our new south, right? That's our south.
And what the way it's taught to me was that was the mind of Egypt.
And the economic section of Egypt was what we see Giza pyramids.
And it's economic. Because if you look at it,
it sits between three continents on the Mediterranean Sea.
So it's a perfect place to carry out commerce. It's the perfect place.
That's why everybody wants to be there. That's why as a war in the Middle East,
because it's the perfect place to be.
So do you believe that some Africans came over here and slave ships or none?
Very minimal. Very minimal. Really minimal. So you think it's a myth almost.
Now, does there any scholars that support these opinions?
Are these your opinions or where are you getting this from? So
here's the thing, this is stuff I've studied probably close to 15 years ago,
so I don't remember a lot of my sources or who I learned it from.
But I can give you a couple of names.
What you gotta do is you gotta look up Shaka outmost.
You gotta look up Dr Cabo Kamin, Dr Phil Valentine, Bobby Hemet.
Uh, who else is a good eater?
Tyler's up.
Shark atmos is a real good egyptologist I think you should start deal with Shaka
atmos, but um, these are,
these are videos I used to watch and Lexis I used to watch back in a day.
Now I focus on like startups. That's where my brain is.
That's where my knowledge is focused on, right?
But a lot of this stuff comes from my own common sense.
It just does not make sense logistically to take people from all the way from
over there to bring them here,
especially when half your stock is going to die when you got people right here,
you have human resources right here. All I got to do is pop them,
shoot a couple of them. The rest of them are like, all right, fine,
and you enslave them and none of them died except for the ones I actually
killed. Right? And I got a whole millions of people right here. Like,
why would I go all the crazy all the way across the ocean to bring people back
across the ocean? That's it. This doesn't make sense. It's a stupid that,
didn't nobody run a business like that. What's up Jim?
PBS? How many the title was?
How many slaves landed in the U F [inaudible].
Well, scroll that up. Scroll it up so I can read that whole thing. Okay.
Right there. Perhaps you like me.
We're raised essentially to think of the slave experience per mile in terms of
our black ancestors here in the United States. In other words,
slavery is primarily about us, right?
From the Crispus attacks and Phillip Wheatley, Benjamin Banneker,
and Richard Allen, all the way to Harriet Tubman. So Jordan,
truth and Frederick Douglas.
Think of it as an instance we were might think of as African American
exceptionalism. In other words, that is the black experience.
It's got to be about black Americans. Well, black Americans will think again,
the most comprehensive analysis of shipping records over the course of slave
trade is the transatlantic slave trade database edited by professors,
David [inaudible] and David Richardson.
While the editors are careful to say that all the figures are estimates,
they believe that the best estimates that we have that proverbial gold standard
in the field of study of the slave trade between 1525 and 1866 the in the entire
history of the slave trade to the new world,
according to the Trans Atlantic slave trade database,
12.5 million Africans were shipped to the new world.
10.7 million survived the dreaded middle passage disembarking in North America,
the Caribbean and South America.
How many of those 10.7 million Africans were shipped directly to North America?
Only about 388,000 that's right. A tiny percentage.
So a small percentage of all the Africans that were enslaved were actually
shipped to North America.
That was probably closer to truth to any come from Africa, bro.
That don't make no sense. Nobody ever run a business like that. Well,
they just saying that a lot of people did though. That's 10.7 million people.
People came on boats. That's what they're saying. That's a true slave trade.
I don't know if that means that they necessarily came here.
They could have been going to Europe. They know that they were [inaudible].
They were saying that it was in the Caribbean trade does have to come from
Africa.
I can trade with you right here in America.
But was it to directly to North America is only the under 400,000 right?
Right. Involved in the shipping and going all over the world.
It could be going anywhere from Africa that's less than 10% African shipped.
Yes. That's less than 10% less than 10% in North America,
but 10.7 million Africans in slaves. Whoa. And moved, wouldn't,
yeah, 10.7 survive. Right. Were were shipped,
but it didn't say where they were shipped. It's just to the new world.
New World is very vague. Arbitrary. Only 388,000 actually made it to this,
to North America. This land from Haiti or Jamaica or South.
So you think. Yeah. Right.
So you think that there was probably already a significant population of
Africans that were sea bearing that made it all the way over here? Yes. Well,
if you listen to the words of Hancock and the discussion of prehistoric,
what we would consider pre historic use of boats and ships,
it's probably likely like look at ancient Egypt.
Don't you see pictures of boats? Oh yeah. Oh yeah. So they would bury them.
I mean if you could, there was the, um, what is the big science, uh,
museum in La that had the, the Egypt, uh,
exhibit really recently. It's fucking incredible.
But they had a depiction of the boats they used. Yeah, I mean,
they had boats for sure. They definitely traveled.
So,
so how can you tell me that a civilization had boats before Europe was literate,
didn't come to America, didn't set up shop. It's just not common.
I mean, just, I don't need to read a book to understand that,
but definitely makes sense if they made it to South America. I mean,
if the old macs were, I mean if you look at, you'd pull up a, an image of a,
the Almac heads. This is heavily disputed.
John Henry Clark is author. You should study. John Henry Clark has a book.
They come before Columbus. I mean, look at that. I mean, these all mek heads,
they all looked like that. I sought the America. Yeah. So it kind of,
if you have a hazing you,
there has to be a large population of people in order to create these things,
right. It has to be, you know, these have to be advanced.
So if they're here already in South America,
why are you going to go across the sea when you got people right here?
You get this in slave south, America's connected to America.
You think we didn't come up north and they ready to take that work. Right.
It's just common sense. Well,
particularly when they're finding all this evidence of people that were here
thousands and thousands of years before they ever thought people were. Yeah.
All the evidence in the Grand Canyon from Egypt.
What I don't know about that is that you heard about that?
There might be some gold down there. Oh,
there's this Egyptian gold in the Grand Canyon. Hey,
imagine if they found a fucking Egyptian tomb.
There's Egyptian stuff that's been found in Ohio. Yeah, yeah.
Well I was looking some stuff up at grandma's telling me I'd went home and
looked up the separate mount stuff and like right up the road from where the
separate mountain is.
There's been a couple of artifacts found there like a hundred years ago.
Artifacts and coal mountain pull that up. Yeah. There's mounds
in America, which yeah, it's supposed to be like paramedics or whatever. So
Egypt, Ohio. I don't think it's named after that,
but it's literally like in the same spot. Yeah.
Yeah. There's this, this, this, this history of human travel.
It's fucking fascinating. Circumnavigated this globe before, man, this,
this isn't new stuff. It's new to Europe.
It wasn't new to the African race man, Eh, we, we been here,
they got the mounds, the archeological evidence from Egypt in the Grand Canyon.
It's right there. See, I've never heard that before. That is interesting.
The archaeological evidence in the Grand Canyon is not part of his story.
He's got to keep you thinking he's got to keep the black people thinking you
were slaves and you came from Africa on boats.
That's what they got to keep you ticking.
But you really think that there's some sort of a grand conspiracy withholding
information. Yeah. The universities, scholars,
all these people that are talking about the history of the world,
universities are indoctrination centers still.
The worst thing you could do is send a child to college unless they're going to
learn a hard science.
You know when you go to wait a minute and you think gender studies is bullshit,
of course is boys in it. What are you saying? These make-believe degrees,
gender studies, Bro. Serious stuff. Yeah. Gender study. You know,
it's a social construct. I stand it.
I study gender in the bedroom and my girl bomp bomp bomp on.
That's why I study gender. Okay.
And no such thing as no genders texts in school tell me. But there is,
you can pay for it and be in debt for studying gender studies.
You can get a fat degree. Yeah. Do you a you find anything about the Egyptian?
Yeah,
when I found it I was down a deep hole. So like I can't just find it that way.
I'm trying to, I sent it to somebody so I'm going to, I'll find it in a second.
Google here. I just found the picture found. Pull it up.
Oh. See some shit. This is, this is the hoteps got to get his glasses on.
We're getting serious. This is the good stuff, man.
That we look at his head. You see his head right there? Yeah.
That's not nappy hair. Um, well that's a tie. Buddha.
So that's not his hair. Well I think those are braids.
This was like an ornamental braids. A lot of people including the Romans. Oh,
like Rachel Dosa don't lose. Oh, what is this
draw? This is from an old book. That's what I was telling. It's really old.
This is a drawing of all the inscriptions that were found on this piece of
stone. And a lot of these are very, they're like hieroglyphs and whatnot.
See Attendance. A couple of, there's like a somewhere on, here's that.
I think that looks just like that serpent from the mountain that's in Ohio. Wow.
Yeah. I forget what effect does necessarily Egyptian, but it certainly,
it might not be Egyptian necessarily,
but when I found it that's what it was tagged as.
It could be just from that time period or very similar, but
that's is the Pennsylvania archeologist is what the book is found from. Okay.
Just how I got to it. I'd never seen this before,
but there is some archeological evidence on the walls. Like you said,
a lot of people don't even know that Egypt's in Africa. This is hilarious.
You start talking to
people about, look, think about that African culture. Why do change is Africa?
Why don't they want the seven wonders of the world to be associated with Africa?
Well, because Africa is a continent, I guess they think of it in terms of,
cause you Egypt is so unbelievably unique globally. Yeah.
Like there's nothing like it in the world. We know Stone Ages in Europe. Yeah.
But Stonehenge is clunky in comparison to the shit that you find in Egypt.
Oh yeah. It is. But they, but they, they, they still pop up Stonehenge.
Like it's some great thing and you know, it's in Europe. Yeah.
Stonehedge is fascinating. Right? It's fascinating. Like, hmm, why they do this?
There's a lot of shit in Europe too.
They're finding now with lidar where they're using this a,
they can map into the ground and find these structures and roads and pathways
that existed and the long since been reclaimed by nature. Yeah.
You're finding that like,
this was one of the Graham Hancock things and he was talking about how you look
at South America when they're going through the Amazon,
you're finding these incredible structures and incredible roadways and
irrigations and that. Huh?
They believe that at one point in time there was civilization of 20 million
people living in the Amazon and that when the European settlers came over,
they brought smallpox and wiped everybody out. Bone. Yeah. Bone.
Just like they did with the native Americans.
A sad thing that people don't know when they talk about native American
genocide, the vast majority is disease. Disease. Yeah. So when people say,
Oh, you know, the white man came over here with violence, I'm like, Nah,
I don't know if he was that violent.
I don't think that he had enough bullets to kill that many people.
They killed 90% with disease state disease. Man, it's just fucking crazy.
The way to disease come from Europe, dirty people. So, so how can the streets,
so how can you tell me that, you know, uh,
I'm just a slave, right. When the filth,
the degeneration of Europe is what came to America.
Greatness didn't come to America. Degeneration came to American.
Some greatness did to, I mean this,
I mean when we talk about the people that came here,
they were escaping the oppression of yes, Europe,
they are the undesirables in Europe. Right.
Or the people would try to get away from religious persecution, right?
Things like that. Yeah. But these were the dregs of the society, right?
In many ways. Yeah. Yeah.
So you come here and you're dirty and you infect the people and then maybe not.
That's why you got to go to Africa ways cause you to go there.
Everybody have it there cause everybody's done. Dude, what,
what if you had to,
like if you were speaking in front of Congress yeah.
When you were talking about reparations, what would you have to say?
Keep the conversation going. Open up the conversation.
Let's get more minds involved. Um, don't shoot it down.
Uh, in Dems must pay, you know,
I've got the Hashtag on Dems must pay wide dems cause this is a great start.
Number one. So, you know, when we had the debate with CJ Paris and he said,
you know, in his rant, you know,
he went off about [inaudible] and he said if anything,
the dams should pay as deliberate rules because they had the KKK had they own
slavery, they ran the slave trade, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah. So it was like,
well if that's the case then why don't we make them pay. The other thing is,
you know, if you're conservative and you, you know, you have in this, uh,
elect election race or whatever,
why don't you just take the wildcard away from them, you know,
from the left and say, well, yeah, you know,
if there is a reparations conversation, you know, that was the Democrats.
That was the Dixie correct. That installed black codes in South Carolina.
They're the ones that, um, that's an interesting conversation, right?
When you say that and like, Whoa, wait, what does that actually,
the Democrats are responsible. Yeah.
You had the thing called black coats and if you were considered black,
then you didn't have rights.
The funny thing is you could be technically African and be white.
White isn't a color, it's a status. Elon Musk,
what do you mean it's from Africa? Everything. Yup. Wow. I knew that,
but he's not an African, well, he was born in Africa,
but he's not in African and South African, but so, so when we do his a 23andme,
what does is probably Dutch or something [inaudible] something from Europe.
Okay, yeah. See what I'm saying?
But there's white people that their lineage from historically is from Africa.
I'm sure. Well, I mean the Sephardic people that lived in northern Africa,
right? Yeah. Where it's considered more Middle East. Right, right, right.
You can see some of that. Absolutely. But these people aren't,
the African people come from Turkey. Right, right.
Come from Kiev, Russia, you know,
that's where they come from and they migrated into Africa.
That's not where they from.
Their bodies aren't even biologically conducive to that environment.
You know,
I'm not conducive to the New York environment wife who is exactly,
but white folks is running down the street when shorts and I'm just like, Yo,
I need a jacket.
There's definitely a biological difference that we got to recognize where we
came from. Yeah. You know? Um, yeah.
I don't know. It's, it's a lot to this conversation. There's a,
it is a lot to this conversation, but it's so heavily weighted.
People don't want to be objective about it. Right. What's up?
The thing I found about the Egyptians in Ohio was actually from a paper that was
written. It's, it's postulating, it,
I guess they took a lot of the evidence that had,
they had been finding and saying this shows that there might have actually been
Egyptians there from 1937 that's when the guy was, I think born,
this is 40 years ago that I emulate was brass apparently.
And it was found near Cincinnati and where I actually think it might've been
trading trade routes cause there was some like a stones that had been found in
various parts of the world that are from specifically Ohio because it's like a
rainbow shale that was using like arrowheads and stuff a long, long time ago.
That area was used to make weapons like the first,
like 12,000 years ago in the first people were kind of in North America.
But that area in Ohio also is known as the stand stone capital of the world.
And I don't know if that's related to the Egyptians cause that's what the
pyramids are made out of. You know,
there's tons of sandstone that is very specific to that region.
So pyramids made a sandstone. I thought so, yeah.
There's 21 from 1800 to 1980 21 times.
The amount of sandstone that made the great pyramid was shipped out of Ohio to
make various buildings all over the world. Most of them United States obviously,
but all over the place.
Don't, don't,
don't just weird facts I found at the grand jury through the human,
no history.
We know some are only the only history that we know is the one we go discover on
our own time. The one that's presented to us is not history. It's all lies.
Well, it's not all lie. All love is some lie.
I found that to lost civilization and Grand Canyon was wait Egyptian and the
Smithsonian published some stuff in 1999 now I guess that where all this came
from,
there was a article that got written and I don't know how much of it they proved
or proven or it was just newspaper Bait back.
They listen.
The more amazing the artifacts didn't match up to anything on the known record
rather than appearing to be of native American origin as one might expect.
The object had distinct Egyptian or Tibetan designs.
Could there have been an entire civilization of Egyptians living here? If so,
how do they get here? Dunk Dunk, hop in the boat,
man.
You got cats that leave Africa and try to come to spay and all these places or a
chicken wing. Yeah. It is interesting,
right?
Like the population of Cuba Cuba's so insanely diverse and it's right there.
Like what is the history of that other than the slave routes?
Like what is the history of Cuba? Because Cuba is very distinct.
African people live in there,
the whole Caribbean, all that whole area is, uh,
has a lot of African roots to it. Um,
but that's just a place that was conquered by to Spain, you know, by,
by the Cortez's, you know, those type of people. Um,
but what really disturbs me is there's no way to know exactly what happened.
It's like you're piecing things together based on artifacts and historical
record things that people wrote down and journals and logs. And
yes, there's people that have traveled. So, again,
I've studied this so long ago,
but I remember reading primary source from somebody that travel with Crystal
Ball, Cologne, Aka Christopher Columbus.
And he was saying very specific things about his accounts when he reached these
different places and you know, and he was saying things like,
we got to the land and we found Africans and he,
I remember him specifically saying, uh, so no matter where we go,
we find Africans. And he said it as if he was disappointed.
And then he started talking about like, you know, this is,
they started talking about the culture and describing their culture.
You just gotta go look at the people that travel with crystal ball Cologne,
and there's some firsthand accounts there and they're very honest about it,
you know,
shoot, I'm going to look into that now. That's a very interesting,
I'm going to ask Graham about that too. What knows about it?
He's studied a me, especially on his latest book. He studied a lot about,
uh, the de various cultures that made it to North America and South America.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. This is very rich in history. Very, very rich answer.
I gotta wrap this up, but, uh, thanks for coming, man.
I had a great time talking to you. Uh, tell everybody it's,
I'm vibe high on h I on Twitter.
No more Instagram. No Instagram. Don't you show your youtube show?
Hoteps been told you every Thursday, 8:00 PM. It's a great name. Alright.
And my main website is Brian Sharp. Dot. COO, B r y e n, s, h as the real mass,
but hotep Jesus's have preferred. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you brother. Appreciate it,
man. That was fun. Thank you. Hotep Jesus, Ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.